My name is Martin. I'm a soldier of Spain and that's it. Most of my life I've spent fighting for land, treasure and the cross. I'm worth millions. Soon I'll be dead and they'll bury me out here in Peru. The land I help ruin as a boy. This story is about ruin, ruin and gold. More gold than any of you will ever see. even if you work in a counting house. I'm going to tell you how 167 men conquered an empire of 24 million. And then things that no one has ever told, things to make you groan and cry out, I'm lying. And perhaps I am. The air of Peru is cold and sour like in a vault, and wits turn easier here even than in Europe.
我的名字叫马丁。我是一名西班牙士兵，仅此而已。我大半生都在为土地、财宝和十字架而战。我身家数百万。不久我就会死去，他们会把我埋在这片秘鲁的土地上。这片我年少时曾帮着毁灭的土地。这个故事关于毁灭，毁灭与黄金。比你们任何人在有生之年见过的还要多的黄金，哪怕你在会计行工作也一样。我要告诉你们，167人是如何征服一个拥有2400万人口的帝国的。还有那些从未有人诉说过的事情，那些会让你们呻吟、尖叫、指责我撒谎的事情。或许我确实在撒谎。秘鲁的空气冷冽而酸涩，就像在地窖里一样，这里的人智计百出，甚至比在欧洲还要容易。
But grant me this. I saw him closer than anyone and had cause only to love him. He was my altar, my bright image of salvation. Francisco Pizarro. And the only wish of my life is that I'd never seen him. So that is the beginning of Peter Schaffer's play, The Royal Hunt of the Sun. It was written for the National Theatre in 1964.
但请答应我一件事。我比任何人都更近距离地观察过他，而且我有充分的理由去爱他。他是我的圣坛，我那耀眼的救赎之象。弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗。我此生唯一的愿望就是从未见过他。这就是彼得·谢弗的话剧《皇家太阳狩猎》的开端。它是为1964年的国家剧院而写的。
So an English play, which is why that Spanish soldier has an English accent, just for people who are wondering. And the Royal Hunter of the Sun was then made into a Hollywood film. And it starred Robert Shaw as Francisco Pizarro or Dominic as Hispanophiles would call him Francisco. Very good film. Very nice. But we're going to call him Francisco Pizarro in this. And also very improbably, coming off the sound of music, Christopher Plummer as Atowalpa, the Great Inca, the Great Inca. and it has to be said that he has a much deeper tann and a much smoother chest than he had in the sound of music.
所以这是一部英国戏剧，这也是为什么那个西班牙士兵会有英国口音，顺便解释给那些心存疑问的人听。《皇家太阳狩猎》后来被拍成了一部好莱坞电影。罗伯特·肖在片中饰演弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗，或者用热爱西班牙文化的人的话说，叫弗朗西斯科。非常棒的电影。非常不错。但在这部播客里，我们要叫他弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗。还有一件极不可能的事，刚拍完《音乐之声》的克里斯托弗·普卢默竟然在片中饰演阿塔瓦尔帕，伟大的印加王，伟大的印加王。必须得说，他的皮肤比在《音乐之声》里黑得多，胸膛也光滑得多。
And it is actually quite shocking to think that from that film, which came out in 1969, he would go on to play the Duke of Wellington in Waterloo, which came out the following year. So it's slightly mind-boggling. But listen, we're not talking about films because this series is going to be one of the most epic, one of the most astonishing we've ever done. And it tells the story of one of the most extraordinary. ordinary episodes in the whole of world history, isn't it? Yes.
想到这部1969年上映的电影之后，他竟然会在第二年上映的电影《滑铁卢》中扮演威灵顿公爵，其实还挺让人震惊的。所以这有点让人难以置信。不过听着，我们不是在聊电影，因为这个系列将是我们做过的最具史诗感、最令人惊叹的系列之一。它讲述了世界历史中规模最宏大、最不同寻常的事件之一，不是吗？是的。
So the exoticism and the drama of the story captured by that play, which is a brilliant play, by the way. So this is the story of the conquest of the empire of the Incas, an empire that stretched from north to south some 2,500 miles. It was the longest empire in history. And it ruled millions of people, probably not 24 million, as they claim in the play, but still a lot. And it's conquered by a few hundred Spanish conquistadors, so fewer than 200, really. It's an adventure story with an amazing range of characters. So two of them you've mentioned.
因此，那部戏剧捕捉到了这个故事的异国情调和戏剧性，顺便说一句，那是一部极其精彩的戏剧。所以，这就是关于征服印加帝国的宏大故事，这个帝国从北到南绵延约2500英里。它是历史上最狭长的帝国。它统治着数百万人，可能没有戏剧里宣称的2400万那么多，但依然数量惊人。而它却被几百名西班牙征服者——实际上不到200人——所征服。这是一个拥有惊人角色阵容的冒险故事。其中有两个人你已经提到了。
The doomed emperor Atowalpa, played by Christopher Plummer, and the man in that reading, the illiterate Spanish buccaneer, Francisco Pizarro. But it's one of these hinge moments in world history. It's a landmark in the story of colonialism. And actually, it's... I sort of thought of this as the third part of a trilogy. So in February 2020, we did a series about Columbus's voyages to the Caribbean.
由克里斯托弗·普卢默饰演的命运悲惨的印加皇帝阿塔瓦尔帕，以及刚才朗读中的那个人——目不识丁的西班牙海盗弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗。但这是世界历史上的关键时刻之一。它是殖民主义史上的一个里程碑。实际上，它……我有点把它看作三部曲的第三部分。所以在2020年2月，我们做过一个关于哥伦布航海前往加勒比海的系列节目。
So that was episode 3. 306 onwards. They love us to give the numbers, Tom. Then in the autumn of 2023, we did an epic series at that time our longest about the fall of the Aztecs, the conquest of Mexico. That was number 385 onwards. We've said that the conquest of Peru is one of the most extraordinary stories ever told. But I mean, the mad thing is, is that the conquest of Mexico is as well. Yeah. And this is the sequel, really. I mean, it really is the sequel, because everybody who's taking part in this adventure has that model. in their minds. So what do you call it? Alien Contact 2. Yes, I guess so. It's the return of the
那是第3集。从第306集开始。汤姆，他们可喜欢我们报集数了。然后在2023年秋天，我们做了一个史诗级的系列，也就是我们当时最长的一个系列，讲的是阿兹特克的灭亡和墨西哥的征服。那是从第385集开始。我们说过征服秘鲁是史上最不寻常的故事之一。但我的意思是，疯狂的是，征服墨西哥同样也是。是的。而这其实是续集。我的意思是，它确实是续集，因为所有参与这场冒险的人，脑子里都有那个参照模板。所以你管这叫什么？《异形接触2》。对，我猜是的。这就是那个
king to the two towers of the four of the Aztecs. And the amazing thing about this is it's one of those sequels that is just as good as the prequel. Definitely it is. Definitely. So we're a few years after the fall of the Aztecs. We'll be telling the story of Pizarro's first expeditions in the 1520s, his arrival in Peru in 1532, the capture and murder of the Inca Emperor Atahualpa, the battle for the Inca capital of Kusko, the flight of the Inca's into the jungle, and the story of the legendary city of Vilka Bamba, which was the last refuge, the lost refuge, actually, of the last Inca's. So it's a very, very melodramatic story, and we shouldn't waste any more time before plunging right in.
回归的国王，面对的是阿兹特克的双塔或四塔。而这个节目神奇的地方在于，它是一部丝毫不逊色于前传的续集。绝对是的。毫无疑问。所以，这是阿兹特克灭亡几年后的事了。我们将讲述皮萨罗在16世纪20年代的首次远征、他在1532年抵达秘鲁、印加皇帝阿塔瓦尔帕的被捕与谋杀、争夺印加首都库斯科的战役、印加人逃入丛林的故事，以及被称为维尔卡班巴的传奇城市的故事——这里是最后一批印加人的最后避难所，或者说失落的避难所。所以这是一个非常非常具有情节剧色彩的故事，在深入探讨之前，我们不应该再浪费时间了。
And maybe Tom, we should start with our protagonist. So that's the man that Martin, who you voiced so splendidly, is talking about in that introduction. And this is the conquistador who changed the lives of millions of people, Francisco Pizarro. Francisco. Yeah, and we will, as in the Aztec series, we will be trying to reflect the linguistic diversity of the newly united Spain by doing a huge range of Spanish accents from different regions.
也许汤姆，我们应该从我们的主角开始讲起。这就是马丁在引言里谈到的那个人——由你进行了如此精彩的配音。这就是改变了千百万人命运的征服者，弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗。弗朗西斯科。是的，就像在阿兹特克系列里一样，我们将通过模仿不同地区的各种西班牙口音，来试图反映这个刚刚统一的新西班牙的语言多样性。
And pronunciations. There will be no internal consistency, but a word of warning for our American listeners, we will not be pronouncing them in the strange way that you do. So you just have to suck that up. Right. So Pizarro, hero, villain. It's for the listeners to decide. He's born in 1478 or so in a place called Trujillo in Extramedura, which is the kind of
以及发音。这里不会有什么内部的一致性，但要对我们的美国听众发出警告，我们不会用你们那种奇怪的方式来发音。所以你们只能忍着了。好吧。那么，皮萨罗是英雄还是恶棍？这由听众来决定。他大约出生于1478年，在一个叫特鲁希略的地方，位于埃斯特雷马杜拉，这里可以说是西班牙的
wild west of Spain. Has a lot of storks. Yes, exactly. A lot of castles. It's sun bleached. It's a very poor country, very violent, bandits. Spaghetti Western, isn't it? Spaghetti Western Territory.
蛮荒西部。有很多鹳。是的，没，错。有很多城堡。这里阳光惨白。这是一个非常穷困的地区，非常暴力，有强盗。意大利西部片，对吧？意大利西部片的地盘。
Yes. It's kind of place that basically you leave if you want to be successful, which is why so many of the conquistadors, Enan Cortez and Francisco Pizarro, most famously, came from extramadura. And you can leave because it is a land that breeds tough men. So Francisco is the illegitimate son of an infantry officer who belonged to the minor nobility. And his mother was a servant girl with whom this infantry officer had had a liaison. She brought him up. He never learns, so he's very unlike Ann Annan Cortez. He never learns to read and write. Later on, people would say to mock him that he was a former pig herder. He'd herded pigs in the fields, which is perfectly
是的。基本上，如果你想出人头地，这就是那种你会选择离开的地方，这也是为什么那么多征服者——埃尔南·科尔特斯和弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗，最著名的两位——都来自埃斯特雷马杜拉。你能离开，是因为这是一片孕育硬汉的土地。所以弗朗西斯科是一名步兵军官的私生子，这位军官属于下层贵族。他的母亲是一名女仆，这位步兵军官曾与她有过一段情。是他母亲把他抚养长大的。他从来没学过读写，所以他跟埃尔南·科尔特斯非常不一样。他从不识字。后来人们嘲笑他时说他以前是个猪倌。他在田野里放过猪，这完全
plausible because there's lots of pigs in extreme major, famous for its ham. But he seems to be welcome at the Pizarro family mansion in the town square. And there, very probably, he first met a distant cousin, a much younger boy called Eernan Cortez, whose mother was a Pizarro and was from the Pizarro clan. In the late 4090s, when he was in his teens, he may have gone with his father to fight in the wars in Italy. Can't be sure. But if he did, he didn't stay there for long, because if you're from extra majora, if you're keen to seek your fortune, in the 1490s a much more exciting and lucrative place has just opened up. When Pizarro was 14 years old, in 1492, Columbus first sailed to the new world.
是有可能的，因为埃斯特雷马杜拉有大量的猪，以火腿闻名。但他似乎很受镇中心皮萨罗家族大宅的欢迎。正是在那里，他很可能第一次遇到了一位远亲，一个比他小得多的男孩，名叫埃尔南·科尔特斯，他的母亲也是皮萨罗家族的人，出自皮萨罗宗族。在15世纪90年代末期，当他还是个十几岁的少年时，他可能曾随父亲去意大利参加战争。这无法确定。但如果他真的去过，他在那里也没有待多久，因为如果你来自埃斯特雷马杜拉，如果你渴望在14世纪90年代发财，一个更加令人兴奋、更有利可图的地方刚刚对你开放。当皮萨罗14岁的时候，也就是1492年，哥伦布首次航行到了新世界。
And when he is 17 years old, so in 1495, the Spanish monarchs, Ferdinand and Isabella, basically scrap Columbus's monopoly and open up the Indies to any Spaniard who will pay them a share of the prophets. So this is now the kind of gold rush, as it were, is on. And by the end of the 15th century, hundreds of Spaniards, people from Pizarro's kind of background are seeking their fortune on Hispaniola and Cuba and on the other Caribbean islands. And Pizarro is one of them. He actually went before Cortez did. He landed on Hispaniola in 1502 and he became a soldier and he made a name for himself as a man who will do what needs to be done. And basically doing what needs to be done is massacring the local people, the tainos.
而当他17岁的时候，也就是1495年，西班牙君主斐迪南和伊莎贝拉基本上废除了哥伦布的垄断权，向任何愿意将利润分给他们的西班牙人开放了西印度群岛。所以现在的淘金热，可以说是拉开了帷幕。到了15世纪末，数百名西班牙人，也就是皮萨罗那种背景的人，都在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛、古巴和其他加勒比海岛屿上寻求发财的机会。皮萨罗就是其中之一。他其实比科尔特斯去得还早。他在1502年登陆伊斯帕尼奥拉岛，成为了一名士兵，并通过做一个“必须去做的事”的人而名声大噪。基本上，那些必须做的事就是大屠杀当地人，也就是泰诺人。
I mean, just to add a kind of interesting detail on that, that there's going to be a lot of massacring coming. But a person who sailed with him on that expedition to Hispaniola was Bartolome de Las Casas. Oh, yeah. The man who, in due course, will become the great spokesman of the rights of the native peoples in America. And that is going to be an enduring tension
我的意思是，顺便补充一个有趣的细节，接下来会有很多大屠杀。但当年和他一起远征伊斯帕尼奥拉岛的其中一个人，是巴托洛梅·德拉斯卡斯。哦，是的。这个人后来将成为美洲原住民权利的伟大代言人。这将是16世纪新世界西班牙历史上一场挥之不去的紧张关系，
throughout the course of Spanish history in the New World in the 16th century, which we should not forget about. I think as with the Aztec series, if you just think of the Spanish as blood-soaked greedy, that's not quite right. They were always arguing about what to do, but also a huge theme of this series, as it was in the previous one,
我们不应该忘记这一点。我认为，就像阿兹特克系列一样，如果你只是把西班牙人看作满身血污、贪婪成性的人，那就大错特错了。他们总是在争论该怎么做，而且正如上一部系列节目中一样，本系列的一个巨大主题是，
they're very legalistic. They're always arguing about the sort of legal ramifications of what they're doing, and they're always travelling with notariz and stuff. And this whole kind of mad thing where they have to read out a statement, inviting the Native Americans to become Christians and submit to the Spanish king,
他们非常注重法律程序。他们总是在争论自己所作所为在法律上的影响，他们出行时总是带着公证员之类的随行人员。还有这种疯狂的举动：他们必须宣读一份声明，邀请美洲原住民成为基督徒并向西班牙国王臣服，
which obviously is gibberish to the people who are listening to it. But that is going to be an ongoing theme, isn't it? Now, a big theme of the conquistadors experience was that so many of them, this is the age of printed books, so many of them arrive in the new world with their heads full of chivalric fantasies. They're expecting to fight monsters and rescue maidens, and they're very excited at the thought of adventure. Pizarro, of course, is different.
这对于听的人来说显然是胡言乱语。但这将是一个贯穿始终的主题，不是吗？好了，征服者经历的一个重大主题是，由于这是一个印刷书籍的时代，他们当中有许多人满脑子都是骑士传奇的幻想，带着这种幻想来到了新世界。他们期望去与怪物战斗、拯救少女，并且对冒险的想法感到非常兴奋。皮萨罗当然与众不同。
He may know of such things, but he has never read one and he never will, because he still can't read and write. And actually some historians, and indeed some Spanish chroniclers who later very harsh about him, treat him as an illiterate thug. I think that's a little bit harsh. I think he's a much more straightforward man than Cortez. Cortez was very feline, wasn't he was vulpein? Yeah, he was very Machiavel.
他可能听说过这些事情，但他从来没有读过这类书，也永远不会去读，因为他至今仍不识字。事实上，一些历史学家，以及一些后来对严厉批评他的西班牙编年史家，把他当作一个不识字的暴徒。我认为这有点过于严厉了。我认为他比科尔特斯更直率。科尔特斯非常狡猾，不是吗，像狐狸一样？对，他非常马基雅维利。
Yeah. Pizarro is not a Machiavelle. He's a strong man. He's a big bloke. He's very tough. Everyone says he's daring. He's more conservative than Cortez. So he wears black and austere.
是的。皮萨罗可不是个马基雅维利主义者。他是个硬汉，块头很大，非常顽强。所有人都说他胆识过人。他比科尔特斯更保守。所以他总是穿着黑色、简朴的
kind of black and white costume which he wears all his life. Like Philip II. Yeah, his pleasures are simple, playing bowls, kind of ball games. Do you think the kind of sense of him as an illiterate thug is reflecting class bias then on the part of chroniclers who despise him for his illiteracy? Yes, a little bit, a little bit. And there's so much feuding that once people have fallen out with Pizarro, they say, oh, you're a former pig herder, you can't even read, you're just a bruiser,
黑白服装，这种服装他穿了一辈子。就像腓力二世一样。是的，他的爱好很简单，喜欢打地滚球之类的球类游戏。你觉得人们把他视作不识字暴徒的这种印象，是否反映了那些鄙视他文盲身份的编年史家的阶级偏见呢？是的，有一点，确实有一点。而且人与人之间的争斗太多了，一旦有人和皮萨罗闹翻，就会说：“哦，你以前是个猪倌，你连字都不识，你不过是个打手”，
all of this. But actually at the time, his men generally saw him as quite an easy-goer. I mean, definitely the Italians didn't, but his men saw him as an easygoing kind of chap. So one of the things about the conquest of the Inca's, a lot of the conquistadors wrote memoirs about their time in Peru. And of course, those memoirs may be fictionalized or maybe distorted, but there were really interesting kind of insights into what went on. And, I mean, you have a kind of critical mass of accounts.
诸如此类的话。但事实上，在当时，他手下的人普遍认为他挺随和的。当然，意大利人肯定不这么觉得，但他手下的人觉得他是个随和的家伙。所以关于征服印加帝国的特点之一，就是许多征服者都写了关于他们在秘鲁经历的回忆录。当然，这些回忆录可能是虚构的，也可能被扭曲了，但它们确实提供了非常有趣的见解，让我们得以一窥当时发生了什么。而且，我的意思是，你们拥有一类数量相当可观的记载。
You guess, I mean, they can't all just be made up, right? No. So one Spanish chronicle and one memoir said, he was a good companion. without any vanity or pomposity. A later chronicler, who was actually half Inca, called Garthelazzo, said he was kindly and gentle by nature and never said a hard word of anyone. I mean, how kindly and gentle Pizarro was, we shall discover. He is a soldier's son from a very violent part of Spain.
你猜，我的意思是，它们总不可能全都是凭空捏造的吧？没错。所以有一位西班牙编年史家和一份回忆录说：“他是一个很好的同伴，没有任何虚荣或自命不凡。”另一位后来实际上有一半印加血统的编年史家加尔西拉索说，他天性仁慈温和，从不对任何人恶语相向。我的意思是，皮萨罗到底有多仁慈温和，我们接下来就会发现。他是一个来自西班牙暴力地区的士兵之子。
This is a very violent business. And Pizarro, as we will find out, will do whatever it takes and he will kill whomever he needs to kill in order to get out on top. There is your shout line for the film. He will kill whoever he must to come out on top. Okay. Wow. That's, yeah, I mean, I can see it now.
这是一项充满暴力的事业。正如我们将发现的那样，皮萨罗会不惜一切代价，他会杀死任何需要杀死的人，以便能够出人头地。这就是那部电影的宣传标语。为了出人头地，他会杀死任何必须杀死的人。好吧。哇。这，是的——我的意思是，我现在就能想象出来了。
Who is he played by Robert Shaw? I mean, I like Robert Shaw as an actor. So for the next 20 years or so, he's in the Caribbean. He's a pretty obscure figure. So we talked in the Columbus and Aztec series about the conquistadors and how they operated, these chains of conquest. They would basically have rival networks of entrepreneurial, kind of of freebooters and adventurers and whatnot, who would be engaged in island hopping across the
谁来演他？罗伯特·肖吗？我的意思是，我挺喜欢罗伯特·肖这位演员的。所以在接下来的二十年左右里，他一直待在加勒比海地区。他是一个相当默默无闻的人物。所以我们在哥伦布和阿兹特克的系列里谈到过征服者以及他们是如何运作的，也就是这些连锁征服。他们基本上会拥有相互竞争的创业型网罗，由各种自由靴兵、冒险家之流组成，他们在加勒比海岛屿之间跳跃穿梭，
Caribbean, getting closer and closer to the American mainland. And obviously the most celebrated of all these networks, of all these operations, is Cortez's, when Cortez went from Cuba to Mexico and then from there into Central America. Pizarro joins a different company from his cousins, a company operating much further south, and they're basically hacking their way through the jungles of Central America and Panama and stuff. Which is lacking in the kind of splendid civilizations that Cortez finds. So there is a slight sense that there's kind of a bit of luck, isn't there? Completely. It's like your venture capitalists and you're investing in tech firms, and some of them will pay off and some of them won't, and Pizarros has not really paid off.
越来越接近美洲大陆。当然，所有这些网络、所有这些行动中最著名的，就是科尔特斯的那一次，当时科尔特斯从古巴前往墨西哥，然后从那里进入中美洲。皮萨罗加入了与他的表亲们不同的另一家公司，一家在更南方运作的公司，他们基本上是在中美洲和巴拿马的丛林中披荆斩棘。而这里缺乏科尔特斯所发现的那种灿烂文明。所以会有一种运气的成分在里面，对吧？完全是这样。这就像你是个风险投资人，在投资科技公司，有些公司能成功回报，有些则不能，而皮萨罗的投资并没有真正回报。
That said, he's part of the group that become the first Europeans to lay eyes upon the Pacific. Yeah, so not Stout Cortez, as John Keats said. Got it wrong. No, it's Balboa. Vasco Nunez de Balboa, who leads that operation. And here's a very good example of how the Conquit Christodores' lives work. Pizarro is standing with him when they look out on the waters of the Pacific. And six years later, it is Pizarro who arrests Balboa and brings him for execution in Panama because of the endemic feuding that is always tearing the conquistadors apart. So they're basically always worried.
话虽如此，他是第一批亲眼见到太平洋的欧洲人这个群体中的一员。是的，所以不是约翰·济慈所说的那位“壮硕的科尔特斯”。弄错了。不，那是巴尔沃亚。瓦斯科·努涅斯·德·巴尔沃亚，正是他领导了那次行动。这里有一个很好的例子，说明了征服者的生活是如何运作的。皮萨罗就站在他身边，当他们眺望太平洋的海水时。而六年之后，正是皮萨罗逮捕了巴尔沃亚，并把他带到巴拿马处决，原因就是那种总是将征服者撕裂的根深蒂固的内斗。所以他们基本上总是提心吊胆的。
You know, you can team up with somebody and go on some amazing expedition and risk your life and whatnot. And three years later, that person will sink a knife into your back and steal of your money. or you'll be involved in 20 years worth of lawsuits in Spain or you'll die of some hideous disease in the jungle. All of these things will happen in this series. So if we fast forward now to the beginning of the 1520s, Pizarro who is now in his early 40s,
你知道的，你可能会和某人结伴去进行一次惊险的远征，冒着生命危险等等。结果三年后，那个人就会把匕首插进你的背脊，偷走你所有的钱。或者你会在西班牙卷入长达二十年的诉讼，或者你会死在丛林里某种可怕的疾病中。所有这些事情都会在这个系列中发生。所以如果我们现在快进到16世纪20年代初，当时皮萨罗已经四十出头了，
has settled in the boom town of Panama City. So Panama City is booming, but it's a kind of pretty rough. It's a kind of place of pub brawls and stuff. Star Wars bar. The canteen are in Star Wars, exactly. Pissarro has done pretty well for himself. He has his own estate, is called an encomienda, which comes with a grant of indigenous labourers, who basically,
他在繁荣的巴拿马城安顿了下来。所以巴拿马城正在蓬勃发展，但它是个相当粗野的地方。那是一个充满酒吧斗殴之类的地方。星球大战酒吧。就是《星球大战》里的那个小酒馆，没错。皮萨罗自己混得相当不错。他有自己的庄园，被称为“监护征赋制”（encomienda），这附带了一批印第安劳动力，基本上，
you know, as close to slave labour as you can get really. But Pizarro is restless, and the puzzle for historians is working out why he's so restless. Because at this age, in your early 40s, most conquistadors say, that's it now, I'm not trudging through jungles with loads of leeches again. I've had enough. I've made a little bit of money. Is it his Pothos? Yeah, like Alexander. Alexander, the great-style yearning. I mean, I suppose, because he's illiterate, he doesn't have that kind of massive Alexander the great vibe. I think actually the pathos, I think you're underrating it, Tom. Pizarro has quite modest personal tastes. You know, he's not a man given to luxury. He's
你知道的，这已经无限接近于奴隶劳动力了。但皮萨罗是个闲不住的人，历史学家们的谜题就在于弄清楚他为什么这么闲不住。因为在这个年龄，四十出头的时候，大多数征服者都会说：“行了，我可不再带着一堆蚂蟥在丛林里跋涉了。我受够了。我赚了点小钱了。”这是他的求胜欲吗？对，就像亚历山大一样。亚历山大那种伟大的渴望。我的意思是，我想，因为他不识字，所以他没有那种强烈的亚历山大大帝式的氛围。我觉得其实这种求胜欲，我觉得你低估它了，汤姆。皮萨罗的个人品味相当朴素。你知道的，他不是一个沉溺于奢侈的人。他不是一个
not a man given to display. He looks quite conservative. He's not married. He doesn't have children. So it's not like he's interested in piling up gold for his descendants. He has a yearning. Yeah, a thirst to make a name for himself, a thirst for glory. Maybe that's the, uh, the subtitle of the film. It is. And he will gamble in the next seven years. His health is his life, and most importantly for a conglisterdor, all his money, on a pursuit of, well, this is the mystery. What? What does he really think he's after? And the truth is he doesn't know. In 1522, so this is just a couple of years after Cortez had arrived in Tenochtland, the capital of the Aztecs. In 1522, further south, a Basque called Pasquale de Andagoya had sailed southwest from Panama.
好大喜功的人。他看起来相当保守。他没有结婚，也没有孩子。所以这不像是他有兴趣为后代堆积黄金。他有一种渴望。是的，一种扬名立万的渴望，对荣耀的渴望。也许这就是电影的副标题。确实是的。在接下来的七年里，他将赌上自己的健康、他的生命，以及对于一个征服者来说最重要的全部身家，去追求——好吧，这就是谜团所在。什么？他到底觉得自己想要追求什么？事实是，他自己也不知道。1522年，也就是科尔特斯抵达阿兹特克首都特诺奇蒂特兰之后不久，在1522年，在更南方，一个名叫帕斯夸尔·德·安达戈亚的巴斯克人从巴拿马向西南航行。
Tabby was very anxious that people understand the geography, because we're not the rest of geography, but we like to dabble in it from time to time. So Pascal de Andegoya had gone southwest from Panama. So that's basically down the Pacific side of the top of South America. What is now, Colombia? And he'd gone along the coast of Colombia. And he was gone for ages. People thought he'd vanished.
塔比非常急切地希望人们了解地理，因为我们并不擅长地理，但我们不时喜欢涉猎一下。所以帕斯夸尔·德·安达戈亚曾从巴拿马向西南航行。也就是基本上沿着南美洲顶端的太平洋沿岸南下。也就是现在的哥伦比亚？他沿着哥伦比亚海岸航行。他走了好久。人们以为他失踪了。
And then he returned, and he said, I've been in the job. jungle in Colombia. And there are people there, there's not much there, but people say further south, there is this land called Beiru. And Beiru, they say, is a rich and powerful empire, maybe as rich as Mexico. And Dominic, just to ask, there have been no contacts between the Aztecs and the Inca's, have there? And the geography is just too impenetrable and impassable. As we will discover, when we get to the Inca's, they have basically been living in a Yeah, because they're geographically bound in by sea and mountains and jungle and all kinds of things. Yeah, exactly.
然后他回来了，他说：“我一直在哥伦比亚的丛林里。那里有人，虽然没多少人，但人们说再往南，有一个叫比鲁的地方。人们说，比鲁是一个富裕而强大的帝国，可能和墨西哥一样富裕。”多米尼克，我想问一下，阿兹特克人跟印加人之间从来没有过任何接触，对吧？而且那里的地理环境实在太难以逾越和通过了。正如我们将要发现的，当我们到达印加人那里时，他们基本上是生活在一个——是的，因为他们在地理上被海洋、山脉、丛林以及各种各样的东西包围着。是的，完全正确。
So Pizarro in Panama City, you know, imagine him in his canteen are surrounded by aliens. He says, oh, I like the sound of this. And this is the dream that he will chase. So in the summer of 1524, he forms a partnership with two friends from Panama City. One of them is a priest called Enando de Lucke, who devils in business and has borrowed some money from a judge. And the other, a very important person in this story in all six episodes. It's an old comrade of Pizarro is called Diego de Al Magro. And he's from rural Newcastile.
所以身处巴拿马城的皮萨罗（你可以想象他在星球大战的小酒馆里被外星人包围着），他说：“哦，听起来不错。”这就是他将要追逐的梦想。所以在1524年夏天，他与巴拿马城的两个朋友合伙。其中一个是名叫埃尔南·德·卢克的牧师，他涉足商业，并从一个法官那里借了一些钱。另一个人，则是这个故事中乃至全部六集里都非常重要的人物。他是皮萨罗的一个老战友，名叫迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗。他来自新卡斯蒂利亚农村。
He's a little bit older than Pizarro. He's also legitimate. He's also illiterate. They can't read. And he's another very hard man. People said his body was covered with scars from fighting. But he's literally more colourful than Pizarro. He wears very colourful clothes.
他比皮萨罗稍微年长一点。他也是私生子。他也不识字。他们都不会读书。而且他也是另一个硬汉。人们说他的身上布满了战斗留下的伤疤。但他比皮萨罗在视觉上更显眼。他穿着非常色彩鲜艳的衣服。
And to read you, because it's important to get all these people in their heads. One chronicler said of Almagro, He was a man of short stature with ugly features But with great courage and endurance He was generous but was conceited And was given to boasting Letting his tongue run on sometimes without stop So he's short, he's ugly
为了向你们朗读——因为把所有这些人的形象印在脑海里很重要——一位编年史家这样评价阿尔马格罗：“他身材矮小，长相丑陋，但有着极大的勇气和毅力。他慷慨大方却又自负，有时总是夸夸其谈，喋喋不休。”所以他又矮又丑，
He's very brave And he's boastful And he's always talking about himself I mean this is the film It's just writing itself isn't it There'd be so many actors He'd want to play that part Well not nice because
非常勇敢，爱吹牛，总是自吹自擂。我的意思是，这就是那部电影啊。这剧本简直自己就会写了，不是吗？会有很多演员都想演那个角色。好吧，其实不然，因为
He and Pizarro at this point are great mates And spoiler alert It will not last Not for long. No honour among thieves. So in November 1524, they set off in three small ships down the Pacific coast of Colombia. So this is the top left of South America. And this is not a success at all this voyage.
他和皮萨罗此时还是极好的铁磁。剧透警告：这不会持久。不会长久。盗亦有道？不存在的。于是在1524年11月，他们乘着三艘小船出发了，沿着哥伦比亚的太平洋海岸南下。也就是南美洲的左上角。这次航行完全算不上成功。
The weather's really bad. They put ashore. They get into a fight with some villagers who've got spears and bows and arrows. Amagro loses an eye. So this is great now because we can picture him with an eye patch. I don't think he did wear an eye patch But I think for the purposes of the film What, so he just had a horrid kind of bleeding sore
天气非常糟糕。他们登岸了。他们与一些拿着长矛、弓箭的村民打了一架。阿尔马格罗失去了一只眼睛。太棒了，现在我们可以脑补他戴着眼罩的形象了。我觉得他其实没戴眼罩，但为了电影的效果——什么，所以他只是顶着一个可怕的、流脓的伤口吗？
I think so, yeah Oh, great I think for Hollywood purposes The eye patch is important Who play him? Joe Pesky I'm thinking the bloke who was Gimli John Rees Davis
我想是的，对。哦，太棒了。我觉得为了好莱坞的效果，眼罩很重要。谁来演他？乔·佩西？我在想演吉姆利的那个家伙——约翰·里士·戴维斯。
A Welshman Yeah, more Welsh history And the rest of this is too much Okay, so he's either Gimley or Joe Peske I think Gimley I think Gennelagh's Gimley We still haven't cast Pizarro But we can work on that
一个威尔士人。是的，更多的威尔士历史。剩下的就太多了。好吧，所以他要么是吉姆利，要么是乔·佩西。我觉得是吉姆利。我觉得吉姆利是吉姆利。我们还没选出皮萨罗的演员呢，但我们可以慢慢物色。
In the course of the series Anyway, they go back to Panama Pizarro is undeterred. He raises more money. In March 1526, he and Al-Magro set up again with two small ships, and this voyage will become one of the most celebrated voyages in Spanish history. They go south down the coast of Colombia, that's sort of western coast. And when they get to the San Juan River, Pizarro goes ashore and camps, Al-Magro goes back to Panama to get reinforcements. And they're pilot. So the guy who's basically, you know, piloting the ships, who's a guy called Bortolome Ruiz. he says, I'll take the ships on a little bit, scout on south to see what's there while you guys do what you're doing. Ruiz crosses the equator
在本系列的过程中。不管怎样，他们回到了巴拿马。皮萨罗并没有被吓退。他筹集了更多的资金。1526年3月，他和阿尔马格罗带着两艘小船再次出发，这次航行将成为西班牙历史上最著名的航行之一。他们向南沿着哥伦比亚海岸航行，也就是西海岸的那一带。当他们到达圣胡安河时，皮萨罗上岸扎营，阿尔马格罗则返回巴拿马去搬救兵。而他们的领航员——也就是负责驾驶船只的人，一个名叫巴托洛梅·鲁伊斯的人——他说：“我把船再往前开一点，往南侦察一下看看那边有什么，你们就在这里做你们该做的事吧。”鲁伊斯穿过了赤道，
and then once he's crossed the equator on the horizon he sees a ship and it's basically a raft. It's an ocean-going raft. Oh, like the contickey. With cotton sails and he captures this ship and a lot of this people
一旦他穿过了赤道，他在地平线上看到了一艘船，那其实是一艘木筏。一艘远洋木筏。哦，就像康蒂基号一样。带着棉质风帆，他截获了这艘船，船上许多人为了逃跑而跳进海里之类，但并不是所有人都跑了。他在木筏上发现的东西让他简直不敢相信自己的眼睛，正如他在给西班牙国王查理八世的信中汇报的那样：
sort of jump overboard and stuff to escape him but not all of them. And he can't believe what he finds on this raft because as he reports in a letter to Charles VIII Spain. It's full of gold and silver ornaments. Crowns and diademes, belts and bracelets, tweezers and rattles and strings and clusters of beads and rubies, mirrors and cups and other drinking vessels.
它装满了金银饰品。王冠与头饰，腰带与手镯，镊子、拨浪鼓、成串的珠子和红宝石，镜子、杯子以及其他饮酒器皿。
Tweezers. Tweezers. Tweezers. Tweezers and mirrors. Yeah. Brilliant. Tweezers. The king will be thrilled and have some tweezers. Golden turnipers. Very odd, like, uh, yeah. Maisal hair clippers. Dental floss thing. Dental floss. Yeah. Anyway, they've got all this stuff on the boat. And these blokes on the boat were taking this to trade all this gold to trade unbelievably for brightly coloured fish shells, which they would use as counters. So this is effectively money. Yeah, but what this tells Rui's is that, you know, to trade this for a load of shells
镊子。镊子。镊子。镊子和镜子。太棒了。镊子。国王一定会激动得不行，顺便拿到了几把镊子。金萝卜。非常奇怪，就像，呃，是的。玉米须理发剪。牙线工具。牙线。是的。不管怎样，船上有所有这些东西。船上的这些家伙带着这些金子去进行贸易，难以置信的是，他们竟然用这些金子去换取色彩鲜艳的贝壳，他们用贝壳作为筹码。所以这实际上就是货币。是的，但这对鲁伊斯来说说明了一件事，既然能用黄金换来一堆贝壳，
means that the people with the gold must have an awful lot of it because they don't prize it that highly. Anyway, for Pizarro and Co, this is tremendous news. This is so exciting because this means that clearly is. is an advanced civilization if they're making golden tweezers. And they've got loads of golden rubies and stuff. Exactly. Ruiz keeps three of the blokes on the raft on afterwards to train as interpreters. And actually throughout this whole story, there are clearly going to be people interpreting
那就意味着拥有黄金的人一定拥有极其大量的黄金，因为他们根本不把黄金当回事。无论如何，对于皮萨罗一伙人来说，这是个天大的好消息。这太令人兴奋了，因为这显然意味着，如果他们连金镊子都能造出来，那一定是一个高度先进的文明。而且他们还有大量的黄金和红宝石之类的东西。完全正确。鲁伊斯把木筏上的三个人留了下来，以便训练他们当翻译。事实上，在整个故事中，显然一直都会有人负责翻译，
the whole time. And we know virtually nothing about them. And the one thing we do know, actually, is the Spanish, unlike in the story of the Aztecs, the Spanish spends a lot of time complaining that their interpreters are useless and they're mistranslating. what is being said. Because there's no equivalent of Melinche. There's no Melinche, no.
而我们对他们几乎一无所知。我们唯一知道的一点是，与阿兹特克人的故事不同，西班牙人花了很多时间抱怨他们的翻译根本没用，把说话的内容都翻译错了。因为这里没有类似玛琳切的人物。没有玛琳切，没有。
Cortez's girlfriend, who, for very complicated reasons, can speak all these various languages. But there isn't an equivalent of that in this story, is there? No, there isn't. There are just generic people who keep getting, the Spanish themselves get them mixed up, as we shall see. But their Spanish do say, and in fact, the Inca's later say, God, your interpreters are absolutely useless. Well, I mean, I don't think you can blame them, because they're having to learn a completely new language.
科尔特斯的印第安女友，因为非常复杂的原因，她会说各种各样的语言。但这个故事里没有这样的人物，对吧？没有，确实没有。只有一些普通人，西班牙人自己也总是把他们搞混，我们接下来就会看到。但西班牙人确实说过，事实上印加人后来也说过：“天哪，你们的翻译简直一无是处。”嗯，我的意思是，我觉得这不能怪他们，因为他们不得不学习一种全新的语言，
and how can they be sure that the language is properly spoken? Yeah, true. I mean, I just think interpreters should do their job, but I have high expectations. Anyway, the Ruiz, the pilot, goes back to the camp, and he sees Pizarro, and Al-Magro turns up from Panama, and they're all delighted by the news of the gold. He's the Welsh guy.
而且他们怎么能确定这种语言被正确地说出来了呢？是的，没错。我的意思是，我只是觉得翻译就该做好他们的工作，但我的期望值很高。无论如何，领航员鲁伊斯回到了营地，见到了皮萨罗，而阿尔马格罗也从巴拿马赶了回来，他们都为黄金的消息欣喜若狂。这就是那个威尔士家伙。
Amagro is, yeah, the guy with the eye patch. And Al-Marro says, look, I'll take some of this goal back to Panama, I'll get more recruits. Why don't you guys keep going, you know, see what you can find. So they go on And they decide their rendezvous On this deserted island called the Isla de Degayo
阿尔马格罗是，对，就是那个戴眼罩的家伙。阿尔马格罗说：“听着，我把一部分金子带回巴拿马去，我能招募更多新兵。你们为什么不继续前进，你知道的，看看你们能找到什么。”于是他们继续前进，
Which is on the border roughly between Colombia and Ecuador So we're now going down The west coast of South America So Pizarro and Co Go to this island Al-Magro goes back to Panama To take the gold back and to get more recruits
并且他们决定在一个名为加约岛（Isla del Gallo）的荒岛上会合，这个岛大致位于哥伦比亚和厄瓜多尔的边界上。所以我们现在正沿着南美洲西海岸南下。于是皮萨罗一行人去了这个岛，阿尔马格罗则返回巴拿马，把金子带回去并招募更多新兵。
When Almagro gets back to Panama The Governor of Panama says This is mad I'm not giving you more people This is a fool's errand But what about the rubies and the gold? Yeah he sees that but he just thinks it's maybe a one-off, it's a maybe a one-off, but also, you know, the weather, the
当阿尔马格罗回到巴拿马时，巴拿马总督说：“这太疯狂了。我不会再给你派人了。这是一场愚蠢的差使。”那红宝石和黄金呢？是的，总督看到了那些，但他只是觉得这可能是一次性的，可能只是个例，而且你知道的，天气、疟疾，你知道的，我们在中美洲还有很多事情要忙。我不会把更多的人扔进去，你知道的，把好钱扔进无底洞，可以说是这么回事。现在，与此同时，皮萨罗和那些留在加约岛这个荒岛上的人，日子过得糟透了。他们的食物吃光了。他们靠吃腐烂的贝壳维生。蚊子把他们咬得遍体鳞伤，
malaria, you know, we've got stuff going on in Central America that we're busy doing. I'm not throwing more men off, you know, more men off, good money after bad, as it were. Now, meanwhile, Pizarro and the men on this desert islands, the East Lad de Gaio, they're having a dreadful time. They're run out food. They're living off like rotten shellfish. Mosquitoes are eating them alive. they've all got dysentery, all of this kind of thing.
他们全都得了痢疾，诸如此类的事情。
Eventually they see ships coming towards them, and Pizarro says, oh, brilliant, these are the reinforcements, these are the new recruits. The ships arrive, and actually the people on the ships say, no, no, we've come to take you back home. You're going back to Panama. Pizarro is gutted, he's furious, and this incredibly famous scene in Spanish history.
最终，他们看到有船只朝他们开来，皮萨罗说：“太棒了，这些是增援部队，这些是新兵。”船只靠岸了，但船上的人却说：“不，不，我们是来接你们回家的。你们得回巴拿马去了。”皮萨罗心碎了，他愤怒极了。接下来是西班牙历史上极其著名的一场场景。
He draws his sword, he gets all his men onto the beach, the men who haven't died of dysentery, and he draws a line in the sand of the beach. And he has this fantastic speech. Comrades and friends, on one side lies comfort. On the other lies death, hardship, hunger, nakedness, rain and abandonment. On that side, you return to Panama to be poor.
他拔出宝剑，把所有没死于痢疾的手下都召集到沙滩上，然后在沙滩的沙子上画了一条线。他发表了一段精彩绝伦的演讲。同志们，朋友们，这一边是舒适。另一边则是死亡、艰难、饥饿、赤贫、风雨与抛弃。在那一边，你们回巴拿马去继续当穷人。
On the other, you go to Peru and become rich. The choice is yours. It's very like when I phoned you to ask if you would like to do a podcast. God, it is. Yeah. He drew a line in the sand and said, on that side is comfort. And the other is golden tweezers. Making this rain and abandonment.
在这一边，你们去秘鲁变得富有。选择权在你们手中。这非常像我当初打电话问你想不想做播客的时候。天哪，确实是。是的。他在沙子上画了一条线，说：“那一边是舒适。另一边则是金镊子。”造就了风雨与抛弃。
And so only 12 crossed, don't they? Only 12 men crossed. And one of them is a very cool guy who's a Greek, who's come from Crete. Pedro de Candea, Pedro de Candea, who's an expert in artillery in firearms. And I just mentioned that artillery and firearms. You know, for no particular reason. I mean, it may not have an impact later on in the plot. Pedro de Kandir is a giant.
结果只有12个人跨过去了，对吧？只有12个人跨了过去。其中有一个非常酷的家伙，是个来自克里特岛的希腊人。佩德罗·德·坎迪亚（Pedro de Candia），他是火炮和火器方面的专家。我顺便提一下火炮和火器。你知道的，并没有什么特殊的原因。我的意思是，它可能对后来的剧情没有什么影响。佩德罗·德·坎迪亚是个巨人。
So the giant Greek and 11 other blokes crossed to Pizarro's side of the line. The rest of them get back on the ship and go to Panama. And for the next few months, Pizarro and these men who become immortalized in Spanish paintings
于是，希腊巨人和另外11个家伙跨过了皮萨罗那一边的线。其余的人上了船回了巴拿马。在接下来的几个月里，皮萨罗和这些在西班牙绘画和文学中被后世永垂不朽的人——也就是著名的“十三壮士”或“不朽的十三人”——留在了这个荒岛上。他们这么做几乎是出于一种顽固，因为他们也不是能去什么地方。他们因此成了好哥们吗？
and Spanish literature later on as the famous 13 or the immortal 13, they stay on this desert island. And they're almost doing it out of stubbornness because it's not like they're going to go anywhere. Are they becoming good mates as a result of this?
他们开始互相看不顺眼了吗？他们成了一帮生死兄弟了吗？你觉得这对他们有什么影响？我想这可能确实营造出了一种生死兄弟的感觉，因为这其中的许多人将继续追随皮萨罗。因为这就是最引人注目的地方，不是吗？他们真的团结在了一起。是的，他们现在全押上了。
Are they getting on each other's nerves? Are they a band of brothers? What effect do you think it has on them? I think it probably does create a band of brothers thing because a lot of these people will carry on with Pizarro. Because that's the striking thing, isn't it? That they really do stick together. Yeah, they're all in now.
他们无法退缩了，因为那样看起来就像个傻子。他们会看起来像绝对的白痴。他们留在了这个荒岛上，皮萨罗变得越来越面容枯槁。最后，领航员鲁伊斯带着一艘船回来了，并说道：“巴拿马总督说，够了，现在回家吧。你们已经证明了自己的观点，基本上没有人会来加入你们了。”
They can't back out because they'd look like fools. They'd look like absolute idiots. They stay on this desert island and Pizarro becoming increasingly emaciated. And then at last, the pilot Ruiz comes back with a ship and says, the governor of Panama said, you know, enough, come home now. You've made your point and basically no one's going to come and join you.
于是，他们极其沮丧地登上了船，而皮萨罗说：“在我们回家之前，我们能最后向南看一眼吗？我们能看一眼岬角周围或其他什么地方有什么吗？”于是他们继续前进，
So very despondently, they get on the ships and Pizarro says, before we go home, could we just take one last look south? Can we just have a look and see what's around the headland or whatever? So they go on
他们进入了瓜亚基尔湾，那是秘鲁和厄瓜多尔交汇的地方，也就是厄瓜多尔南部、秘鲁北部。在那里，他们看到海岸上有一个城镇，他们最终将其命名为通贝斯。他们靠近了那座城镇。皮萨罗的两个人带着
and they go into the Gulf of Goyakil, which is where Peru and Ecuador meet, so southern Ecuador, northern Peru. And there they see a town on the coast, which they end up calling Tombez. And they go near the town. Two of Pizarros, men go ashore with
礼物上了岸，船显然给他们带来了一些食物。他们带着猪和鸡。他们带着猪和鸡的礼物上了岸，当地人非常高兴。所以他们没有被这些猪吓坏吗？我想如果你从来没见过猪，这可能会让人感到不安。他们看起来并没有感到不安。他们看起来
presence of, the ship clearly has brought them some foods. They've got pigs and chickens. They go ashore with the presence of the pigs and the chickens and the locals are delighted. So they're not frightened by these pigs? I think if you've never seen a pig before, it'd be unsettling. They don't seem unsettled. They seem
非常高兴。他们大概会用它做一个美味的火腿三明治什么的。无论如何，那两个家伙回到了船上，他们说：“哦天哪，这正是我们想要的。这是一个真正的文明。这些家伙很有钱。他们穿着漂亮的衣服。他们有首领，还谈到了一个远方的国王。”
delighted. They probably make a nice ham sandwich out of it or something. Anyway, the two blokes come back onto the boat and they say, oh my God, this is what we wanted. This is a proper civilisation. These blokes are pot. They have nice clothes. They have chiefs and they talk about a king far away.
最棒的是，他们拥有非常华丽的寺庙，用白银和黄金装饰。发财了。是的，这正合皮萨罗的心思。太棒了。所以，皮萨罗得到了他所需要的东西。他有了船。有带着镊子的船的证据。他有了那个镇子欢迎猪的到来、并且拥有黄金寺庙的证据。
And best of all, they have very fancy temples decorated with silver and gold. Caching. Yeah, that's up with Pizarro's thinking. Brilliant. So, Pizarro has what he needs. He's got the ship. The evidence of the ship with the Tweezers. He's got the evidence of the town where they welcome the arrival of a pig and they've got temples with gold.
他说：“太棒了。”不仅如此，他们还在这个镇子里找到了
And he says, great. And what's more, they pick up from this town. they're either given or they capture two local boys who they call Martineo and Felipeo, like Little Philip or Little Martin. And these boys, they're going to train as interpreters to add to the ones they've got already
他们要么是被赠予、要么是被捕获的两个当地男孩，他们叫他们马蒂内奥和菲利佩奥，就像小菲利普或小马丁。这些男孩，他们将被培育成翻译，以补充他们原有的那些翻译，
and these boys will play a big part in this story. Because they've grew up actually pretty good, right? Yeah, well, better than the rest. The Spanish keep mixing them up. So in the Chronicles, the chroniclers always disagree whether it's Martineo or Philippio who's translating. But anyway, they've got translators. And the language, of course the Spanish don't know what the language is, but the language that they are translating to and from is a language called Quechua, which is a very big Andean language.
而这些男孩将在故事中扮演重要角色。因为他们实际上长得挺不错的，对吧？是的，好吧，比其他人强。西班牙人总是把他们搞混。所以在编年史中，编年史家们总是在争论到底是马蒂内奥在翻译还是菲利佩奥在翻译。无论如何，他们有翻译了。而这种语言，当然西班牙人不知道那是什么语言，但他们用来互译的语言是一种叫做克丘亚语的语言，这是一种安第斯山脉地区非常重大的语言。
So Pizarro goes back to Panama and he meets his business partners and he says, look, we've obviously got a lot of potential here for another expedition. But we need to get royal approval because we don't want to go down, find stuff and then have competitors come down with royal approval to sort of take all the treasure. So it's that legalistic side again. Exactly. So in 1529 in the spring, Pizarro goes back to Spain and he goes to see the king of Spain, the emperor, Charles V, who's in Toledo in the centre of Spain.
所以皮萨罗回到了巴拿马，他找到自己的商业伙伴说，听着，我们在这里显然有很大的潜力进行另一次远征。
Now, Charles V is a very, very busy man. He's the king of Spain. He's the head of the House of Habsburg. He's the Holy Roman Emperor. He is currently fighting two very expensive wars. One is against the French in Italy, and the other is against the Ottomans in Eastern Europe. So what he wants more than anything is gold and silver from the new world.
现在，查理五世是一个非常非常忙碌的人。
And Pizarro says to him, Your Majesty, you know, I've heard that this place, Biru is brilliant. I've not been there, but I've heard very good things. They have golden tweezers. They have lovely pots. They have nice clothes, all of this. Give you, Your Majesty, a pot. But Charles loves a pot.
皮萨罗对他说：“陛下，我听说毕鲁这个地方太棒了。
If he can melt it down into money for his wars. Now, as luck would have it, also in Toledo at the court, visiting, with loads of gifts for the royal family, is Anne-Cortez. He's making one of his periodic returns from Mexico. Is this where he turns up with loads of Aztec-Mime artists for the Pope? Their bodies are their tools? Is he not always travelling with indigenous people? Well, anyway, Cortez has gone down an absolute storm. And because of that, people are very well inclined to the idea of, oh, there's another Mexico further south.
如果他能把它熔化成军费。
Well, brilliant. So, in July 1529, the Council of the Indies, which is based in Seville, authorises Pizarro to conduct the discovery and conquest and settlement of the province of Peru. And they say to him, you will be the first governor, you'll be its first captain general. If you find it, we will give you a massive salary for life, actually double the salary that's given to Cortez in Mexico. So he's got a really good deal out of it. It's kind of a franchising. Yeah, he's franchise. He's got the franchise.
太棒了。
Pizarro has to put up the capital and take the risk, but he has the brand name. Exactly. There is one catch. When he got the franchise, he accidentally forgot to get a good deal for his business partners. Oh no, the Welsh guy. Yeah, this is how it works. So the guy with only one eye, Diego de Al-Magro, he's going to be the, his reward, while Pizarro has a massive salary and his governor and captain general,
皮萨罗必须自筹资金并承担风险，但他拥有这个品牌名称。
Almagro has been rewarded with the title of Commandant of the Town of Tombez. which is markedly inferior. So he's not going to be happy at all when Pizarro gets back, as we will discover. Anyway, Pizarro goes back from Seville to the New World, January 1530. He's picked up about 200 recruits from his native Extra Madura by and large,
阿尔马格罗得到的奖赏是通贝斯镇的指挥官称号，这明显要低得多。
including six Dominican friars. And Dominic, would one of those friars be called Valverde? He is called Valverde, yeah. The Valverde clan will play an important part in this story. Maybe a doctor of theology. It's a long time since we had a Valverdi on the show. And longstanding listeners will record that when a Valverdi appears on the rest of history,
其中包括六名多明尼加修士。
all kinds of things will follow. Good times follow. Good times follow, exactly. So there's this guy Valverdi who will be playing an important part and there's the three Pizarro brothers. So of these three brothers, they will return in later episodes.
会有各种各样的事情接踵而至。
So get them, remember that they're there. There's the youngest who is called, I mean, actually, there's so much disagreement about what order they're in, how old they are and whatnot. But this is, what I've decided. Juan is the youngest.
所以把他们找来，记住他们在那儿。
He's maybe 19 or so. And everyone said he's very impetuous, his gallant, his young, he's dashing, all of this. Then there is Gonzalo. Gonzalo is the middle one.
他大概19岁左右。
Maybe he's about 20. He's very friendly and easygoing. He was full of nobility and virtue and was beloved and respected by everyone, says the chronicler, Garthilazo. He's the kind of noble one. Juan is the kind of the young scamp.
他有点像那种高贵的代表。
Yeah. What's he? Like. Yeah. And then the third one, what's he like? He's the oldest and he's Enando. Now, Enando, big figure in this story. He's the only one who's legitimate.
第三个是什么样的？
The others are all legitimate. One Spanish Chronicle describes him thus. A tall heavy man with thick lips and a thick tongue. And the tip of his nose was fleshy and inflamed. A great and boastful talker. So Martin Clunes? Yeah, he doesn't sound like a massive looker. But everyone said he was kind of charismatic, charming, impressive.
马丁·克鲁恩斯？
Yeah, big bloke. He's got military experience because he definitely has served in Italy against the French. And he will end up being Francisco's closest confidant, his chief advisor, Enando. And it's there a sense that Italy is where you earn your spurs. That's the kind of cutting edge of military technology. Exactly. Where the Spanish troops are regarded as some of the best in the world, by the way. So by 1530, they're all back in Panama.
没错，西班牙军队也被认为是世界上最好的军队之一。
and Pizarro's planning a new expedition. He does have one problem. His business partner, Diego de Almagro, is absolutely outraged that Pizarro has returned and got him this terrible deal. And Pizarro says, look, listen, when we've got Peru, there must be something underneath it to the south,
皮萨罗正在策划一次新的远征。
and you can have that, and that's what's going to become Chile. So Al-Magro will, you know, he will go off later on to Chile. But that isn't legally stamped, is it? So he doesn't have kind of letters patent from the king or anything. No, no, no.
不，不，不。
And actually, their relationship now is a bit broken and it'll never be the same again and this will run right through this story. I can see why. Yeah, of course, he's really sold him out. He's completely sold him out. And it's worse because Hernando, Pizarro's brother, absolutely despises Al-Magro.
总之，剧透一下，这是一场将毁灭所有这些人的世仇的开始。
Anyway, spoiler alert, this is the beginning of a feud that will destroy all these people. Anyway, 27th of September, 1530, Pizarro sets sail from Panama and is bound for Biru. He's got three ships and 180 men and a load of horses, 37 horses. Now, a crucial point.
阿尔马格罗又犯了同样的错误。
Al-Magro makes the same mistake again. He says, I'll raise more men in Panama and I will follow later. I'll join you later. This is maybe because he's a bit cautious and he wants to find out how things are going to turn out before he risks his life. I assume that, I mean, he doesn't feel quite the blood brother with Pizarro now and so it doesn't feel that they're in it together to the same degree, I suppose.
我想是这样的。
I would guess so. But as we will discover, this is going to have massive consequences. I mean, a lot of people will die because of this. Pizarro and coast sail off down the Pacific coast. The weather's against them this time, so they have to make landfall much early than they planned in what's now the far north of Ecuador. So if you look at a map, top sort of left corner of South America. From there, they start to march down the coast. It's very miserable.
从那里开始，他们开始沿海岸向下行军。
There's loads of mosquito. you know, they're hungry. Pizarro, everyone says, does really well. Like, he's brave, he's big. When they're crossing a river, he will help to carry the sick across on his back, all of this kind of thing. He leads from the front. I mean, whatever else you say about him, he's genuinely brave and he's got tremendous stamina and all this stuff. And concerned for his men. And concern for his men. They reached their first settlement, a town called Kowake in February 1531. They find a load of huts. They find a load of very baffled villagers. And they find a load of emeralds and gold and silver.
而且关心手下的人。
So Pizarro shares a lot of it out. And then weirdly he hangs around in this place, which doesn't sound that thrilling, for about six months. They all come down with the disease. This may be actually, I mean, they're coming down disease because they've hung around,
所以皮萨罗分发了许多财物。
but it may explain why they hang around afterwards. They come around the horrible disease called Carriens disease where you get these massive warts that then bleed, separating warts. Do they stay with you or do they heal? I think they eventually, I mean, if you Google it, you won't forget it. So don't Google it is all I say. Now, everyone will Google it, of course.
现在每个人都会去谷歌搜索了，当然。
Tom's Googling it as we speak. He can't wait to see all those photographs of people's bleeding warts. Oh, my God. You've finally seen those, the Carriens disease. Yeah, guys, whatever you do, do not Google. Carian's disease, warts. Yeah, it's not good. Horrible.
哦，我的天呐。
So now word is spreading about these bearded men who came in floating houses. You know, classic thing like we had with the conquest of Mexico. More reinforcements eventually arrive from Central America from Panama. Al Magro is still not among them. He's still waiting to find out what's going to happen. So eventually Pizarro sets off again. He crosses the equator. He's now going through fields of cultivated maize,
阿尔马格罗仍然不在其中。
what our American listers would call corn. And this implies a high level of social organization. There's farming going on here. People need to be, you need some form of social order for that to happen. and the interpreters are reporting to the Spanish that people are talking about an empire further south and also they're talking about a war but no one really knows what that is intriguing
这暗示着高度的社会组织性。
south of Guyakil in Ecuador big city today they reach a large island called Puna and here the locals are not so friendly they stage a massive dance to trick the Spanish and then turn on them but of course the Spanish theme of this series they have their steel swords against which, you know, there can be no resistance, and they're able to overcome the locals.
厄瓜多尔今天的大城市瓜亚基尔以南，他们到达了一个叫波纳的大岛。
Do they have horses? They do have horses. They've got about 38, 37 horses, again, which absolutely terrify the people of South America, as we will see again and again. You can turn up with two or three horses and you can defeat hundreds of people, thousands of people because they're so frightened of the horses.
他们有马吗？
Because all these rumours start to spread, don't they, that they eat people. My favourite of all the rumours is that it was widely believed that Spanish were incapable. will of walking up hill. That was what the horses for. That's why they had the horses for. Exactly.
因为所有这些谣言开始四处流传，不是吗？
So some more people, more reinforcements arrive among a character who will play a part in the story. A knight from Spain, from Extra Maduro, called Hernando de Soto. Big news in Florida in due course. Yes, he will come to a ristic end in Florida.
德索托32岁。
De Soto is 32 years old. He's another very short man. There's a lot of short people in this story. But he has won a reputation in Central America as a very dashing and brave horseman. That's his great skill. He's like a sort of the person who would be very good at dressage or some such. Nice.
这真是他的大显身手之处。
He'd win gold with Princess Anne. He would. He'd be great pals of Princess Anne, actually. Is he posh? He's a knight. He's an Ilvalgo. Okay, so he is. Exactly.
他是个骑士。
He's one of those kind of menacing posh people. I wouldn't get on that horse if I were you. Yeah. He's a young Charles dance. That's exactly what he is. So Pizarro says to Soto, right, you can be one of my chief lieutenants. Actually, when we get to Peru, the capital, you can be the lieutenant governor of the capital city. And Sauta says, brilliant, I can't wait.
索托说：“太棒了，我等不及了。”
We'll see how this promise works out. I say. Now, now inching closer to this mysterious empire. There's about 400 of them now. So they get some rafts. They cross from this island that they've been on, back to the mainland and to the town of Tumbes that they had visited before. Now, they'd seen the temples, if you recall. They'd seen the people's nice clothes.
现在，他们离这个神秘的帝国越来越近了。
They'd seen all this. But when they get to the town, they can't believe it. Because the buildings are ruined. The streets are deserted. Oh my God. The temples have been looted. What's happened? Yeah, something apocalyptic.
哦，我的天呐。
The Soto goes ahead to find out what's going on. He finds the local chief across the river. He brings them back to Pizarro and the chief says, you know, he doesn't really fill them in on what's happened. But he says, there's a much greater chief who lives far away. And this greater chief lives in a town with gold. and silver jugs and houses and temples walled and roofed with gold. I say. And Pizarro thinks, wow, this is looking good.
我这么说吧。
They continue on. The next place they get to is a little town called Poetos. And here the local chief is friendly. He gives them food and he adds a little bit more detail about what's been happening. He says, I too answer to this great chief, the emperor. And the emperor's rule extends for thousands of miles north to south. But he says, the old emperor has died and his two sons have been fighting for control of this empire, of a civilization that up till now has been totally unknown to the outside world.
我们把它叫做印加帝国。
And the local people called this civilization, Tawantin Soyo, the land of the four quarters. But Tom, we know it as the empire of the Inca's. And so the Inca's enter the chat. And we will find out what they have to save for themselves after the break. Hello, everyone. Massive excitement because we have an update on the Rest Is History Festival. We can finally start revealing some of the massive A-list names that we have joining us at that festival at Hampton Court. Yes, so in case you missed it, on the 4th and 5th of July this year, we will be hosting the inaugural Rest is History Festi.
没错，所以在今年7月4日和5日，我们将举办首届“历史其余部分”音乐节。
at of all places Hampton Court Palace. And this is a festival exclusively for members of the Restis History Club. That's right, Dominic. And as I mentioned, we have some huge names coming. So I will be joined by Mary Beard to talk about what else Rome. And I will also be joined by friend of the show, Ali and Sari, to talk about what else Persia. Yes. And I'll be talking to two other people who've been on the Restis History. Great fan favourites. One of them is the brilliant Tracy Bormann who will be joining us to talk about the secrets of the Tudors. And the other, another massive fan favourite is Katya Hoyer, who will be talking about her new work on Weimar, Germany. So we will let you know who else is joining us in the next episode, but rest assured it is shaping up to be
在汉普顿宫这个地方。
a brilliant, brilliant weekend in the most magnificent and historic setting imaginable. And remember, this festival is exclusively for our members. So if you, you are a friend of the show, then you can enter the ballot for two tickets. If, however, you are part of the elite Athelstan band, then you are absolutely guaranteed, yes folks, guaranteed access to two tickets. Now, you'll receive all the details via email, but if you want more information about the festival or about the ballot, then just click on the links in the episode description. So if you're not a member, then what on earth are you waiting for? line up now at the rest ishistory.com and you don't just, of course, get access to the rest
那么，如果你还不是会员，你还在等什么呢？
history festival. You get access to a host of supplementary benefits as well. Genuinely, we cannot wait to see you there. Hello everyone and welcome back to The Rest is History. It is the autumn of 1532 and top conquistador Francisco Pizarro and his men have finally crossed. into the mainland of modern-day Peru. And Dominiconi now are they beginning to grasp the reality of what they have discovered, an immense land stretching between the Andes and the Pacific.
而多米尼克，他们现在是否开始理解他们所发现的事物的现实，一个延伸在安第斯山脉和太平洋之间的巨大土地。
And this is the Empire of the Inca's. Yeah. So at last we get to the Inca's themselves. So first of all, the Inkers, I think, are a little bit less known than the Aztecs. They're sort of shrouded in mystery. They don't call themselves Inkers, do they? They don't.
是的。
They don't call themselves the Inkers at all. So the reason we call them the Inca's is that they called their emperor, the Sapa Inca, and the Spanish got the word Inca's from that. But they called themselves, as far as we know, they called themselves probably Runa, which means just the people. And they called their country, not Peru. They called it Tawantin Soyo, the land of the four quarters, north, south, east and west. And their history is a little bit obscure because they didn't write anything down.
他们根本不自称为印加人。
They had no writing. be telling me they didn't have wheels next. You're right. You're not wrong. And they don't have pigs, so they don't have the three important elements for any civilization. So basically, what is written about the Inca's is all written by Spanish chroniclers. And we are fortunate in some ways that the Spanish were fascinated by South America and that in, you know, 1530s, 1540s, 1550s, Spanish conquistadors and memoirists and historians are writing lots of stuff down. But what we can't know, of course, is how accurate it really is.
你接下来要告诉我他们没有轮子吧？
But I would guess again that if you have all these, you know, large numbers of people writing accounts, there must be a measure of truth. They can't just be making it up from nothing. I think so. I think absolutely. So the Inca's are not the first civilization in the Peruvian Andes. You know, archaeologists will tell you there were loads of kind of different cultures before. The NASCAR, as in the lines. The NASCAR lines.
纳斯卡，就像那些线条一样。
The Chavine, a very famous civilization called the Tuenaku. Are they famous? They are famous. I talk about nothing else. I mean, the people I hang around with, they're always talking to a Tijuana. I go out in London and in the pubs of London. I mean, I would say, Dominant, I would say they're well known, but I wouldn't say they're famous. I think famous is the word.
查文，一个非常著名的文明，叫做蒂亚瓦纳科。
So, I mean, Tom, Lake Titicaca, the gate of the sun. People are always chatting about that, aren't they? See, that's famous. Okay. So that's the Timinacu's most famous thing. They built this fantastic gate by a lake, and then they went into decline about AD 1000. And then they were succeeded the Tynanacu by this. loads of competing kind of city states and tribes and stuff.
所以，蒂亚瓦纳科最著名的事情就是这个。
And all of these people, so they're Andeans, they developed, as we said before the break, in isolation really from the outside world. Because north of Peru, you have the forests, the highland forests of Colombia. West you have the Pacific. East you have Amazonia, with its dense rainforests. And south, all the way south, you have the wilderness that is Patagonia. So this is by miles the most isolated civilization on the face of the planet. Yeah, I think so. I think so. So it's not like, you know, it's not like a kind of Himalayan kingdom that has been penetrated by, or Japan or. Yeah, by missionaries or traders or whatever. This place is, these people have basically have really been cut off. Now, the Inks themselves, like the Spanish, they are newcomers to the top division, to the big league. And like the Aztecs. And like the Aztecs. So they're originally a pastoral tribe, so shepherds and stuff or whatever, in the valley of the Urubam.
所以，他们就像，这并不像一个喜马拉雅王国，被什么人渗透过，或者日本，或者。
River, which is outside the highland city of Kusko in the Andes, that's about 11,000 feet above sea level. They'd actually physically developed tremendous lung capacity or whatever to live so high up, but they're so thin. And they speak a language called Quechua, which is an Andean language, which precedes the Inca's. They don't invent it or anything. So can I ask, is there a sense among the Inkers as there was among the Aztecs that they are living amid the ruins of previous civilizations and that they're going. gods and their sense of the past is inherited from those civilizations. Yes, definitely there is. Absolutely there is. So particularly this very famous people, the Tewanaku.
是的，绝对是的。
The well-known people. Yeah, really well-known. So a lot of their gods, a lot of their customs, a lot of kind of Andean social mores and whatnot. They are inherited by the Inca's, rather like the Aztecs were their successors to the people of Teotihuacuan and so on and so forth. So the people in the Andes have this creator god, don't they? Biracotcha. Veracoccia, yeah, exactly. So he's an ancient god, not just an Incan god.
他是一个古老的神，不仅仅是印加神。
And he's the top dog. Well, as we shall see, some of the great temples that end up being looted by the Spanish precede the Incas. Yeah. You know, maybe hundreds or even thousands of years old, these religious sites. So yes, absolutely, they're living amid the ruins of civilizations that preceded them. They begin to expand from being just this little tribe in probably the late 13th century. So for context, that's the time when Edward I was hammering the Scots.
然后，到了14世纪50年代，也就是黑死病、百年战争等等的时期，他们正在向邻近的山谷扩张。
Then by the 1350s, that's the time of the Black Death, 100 years war, all that stuff, they are expanding into the neighboring valleys. And historians call this state the Kusko Confederation. And then about a century after that, there's this legendary moment in Inca history, when their rivals, who were called the Chanka, attacked the Kusko Confederation, and the chanker looked like they were going to have the upper hand. And the king of Kusko, who was called the Sapa Inca, he fled the city. But his son, who was called Kuzi Yopanke, rallied the army and he won this tremendous victory.
然后在此基础上，他取代了他的父亲，成为了萨帕·印加，也就是皇帝。
And then on the back of that, he displaced his father and he became Sapa Inca, or emperor. And he took a new name to mark that, which is Pachacuti. And he is the person, Pachikuti, who reorganises and expands the Kusko kingdom into an empire. So he's the Augustus of the Inca's? He is absolutely the Augustus. when the Spanish came and wrote about him more than a hundred years later, they said he's the guy, he's the founding father. So a Jesuit missionary called Bernabe Corbo said,
所以他是印加人的奥古斯都？
he endowed the state with a code of laws, he expanded the official religion, he embellished the temples with magnificent buildings. In short, he overlooked nothing and organized everything. And later archaeologists and writers said, oh, Patrick Cout is absolutely the man. The Augustus, as you called him, Tom. So there's a Victorian explorer called Sir Clements Markham,
所以有一个维多利亚时代的探险家叫克莱门茨·马卡姆爵士，
who said Patrick Couti, he said, was the best all-round genius ever produced by the native races of America. But actually, disappointingly, he may not have existed. What? Yeah, I know. Oh, no. A real shock. That is so classic.
什么？
So I think modern historians now think the Inca's might have made him up as a sort of they needed a founding father figure. It's kind of like, you know, if he didn't exist, you'd need to invent him. Well, that's the thing. So I think we should act as though he did exist. because somebody like him must have done. Yeah, someone of the same name. Yeah, somebody must have expanded the empire.
所以我想我们应该表现得好像他确实存在过。
And so if you believe the traditional accounts, Patrick Couty, his son who was called Tupac Inca, and his grandson, who was called Huena Capac, they massively expand this empire. So they go all the way west to the coast of the Pacific. They go north into Ecuador and Colombia. They go south to Lake Titicacar and the kind of highlands of the high plateau of Bolivia. they go southwest at the top of what is now chilly. So you can imagine them basically expanding throughout western South America. So it's just very, very long and thin. So long. So long.
太长了。
2,500 miles long. Yeah. There's an American writer called Charles C. Mann who wrote an absolutely wonderful book. I never thought I would say this about a book that has a lot of science in it. But it's called 1491, and it's about the new world before Columbus. And amazingly for a really good book, there's a lot of stuff. about pollen and plants and agricultural terracing, but it's really interesting. It is, isn't it?
这真是太棒了，不是吗？
Yeah. And in that book, he says, imagine as though there was one power that ran an empire that went all the way from St. Petersburg in the north to Cairo in the south, but a sort of long, thin empire. That's the Inca empire. Probably, you know, not as in the Royal Hunters of the Sun claimed 24 million people, probably about 12 million people. It's still impressive, though, isn't it?
这也令人印象深刻，不是吗？
I know. And they're living in massive regional diversions. diversity and all of this. And if you're a guy leading an invasion with about 190 horsemen, it doesn't really matter how many millions you're up against. It's two millions. No, exactly. This gigantic country.
这片巨大的国家。
The mad thing is they don't have some of the things that Eurasian empires take for granted, namely the horse, the wheel, the arch, and the written word. They don't have any of those things. So what do they have? What's Inca civilization look like? well, most people are peasants and they live in these kind of thatched huts along the river valleys of the Andes. They don't have any draft animals.
那他们有什么？
There's no horses. There's no oxen in South America. So they don't have wheels because there's no point. I mean, I suppose you could you have a wheelbarrow, couldn't you? You'd think you'd have a wheel barrow? Yes. They don't have them. But they've got lamas, haven't they?
他们有美洲驼吗？
They've got loads of lamas. I mean, if you like lamas, you're laughing because they've got more llamas than anyone. Don't they eat guinea pigs? So guinea pigs, so what they eat, do you want to hear what they eat? Yeah. They eat sweet potatoes. They eat this maize, or Americans would say corn. They eat potatoes, which the great historian John Heming calls Peru's greatest legacy to the world is the potato.
很好。
Nice. They don't have any cows. They don't have any sheep. They don't have any pigs. They have a load of guinea pigs. And that's the national dish of Peru. Quite yum. They drink a kind of beer made from maize called chicha.
他们喝一种用玉米酿造的类似啤酒的饮料，叫做奇查（chicha）。
They chew coca leaves. The Spanish commented that the Incan nobility seemed to be constantly chewing these coca leaves. They're kind of very mild, very very, very. very mild stimulant, basically green of cocaine. Does it make them kind of rush around going on about how brilliant they are? No, I don't think so. Because I mean, reading some of the stuff
这会让他们兴奋得到处乱跑，吹嘘自己有多厉害吗？
that the Inca emperors say about themselves, you think there's a guy who's been on a coca. No, I don't think so, actually, because I think it's so mild the coca leaf. I mean, I've never chewed a coca leaf myself, but anyway, they have a load of llamas, as you say, and alpacas. Now, interestingly, they all wear the same clothes.
现在，有趣的是，他们穿的衣服都一样。
So if you went to the Inca Empire for a stroll, You would see all the blokes wearing kind of brown cloaks and all the women wearing grey cloaks and so on. And this is an important point. This is a standard uniform and no deviation whatsoever is permitted. This is an exceptionally ordered society. So if you think about the Inca's, they've got some massive things that are going against them. They don't have any domestic animals, very few domestic animals. They don't have rich farmland.
这是一个极其井然有序的社会。
And the sort of highlands of Peru, the steep slopes, the Andes is a terrible place to try to grow crops, which is why they have to carve out all these terraces and stuff. And as Pizarro's men march into this empire, they see these stone terraces along the hillsides. They see there's loads of irrigation canals and ditches and an incredible road network. So the largest road network in the Americas, 14,000 miles long, there's these paved stone roads, rope, suspension bridges and almost like kind of primitive cable cars going across. the valleys. And they are crucial in any film, aren't they? You have to have a battle on a swaying suspension bridge with somebody threatening to cut the ropes. Exactly. And all the way, there's
在山谷里。
a chain of kind of warehouses and storehouses along the roads with clothes and with food and supplies and stuff. There's nothing like this in Mexico in the Aztec Empire. And in fact, some of the Spanish say, there's nothing like this in Europe. I mean, an incredible road network. But you'd have to have it, because otherwise you couldn't. run an empire that's that long. That's that long. But to have it at all, that tells you how this empire is working. So the Inca's, you know, they don't get people to build these roads out of, you know, voluntary enthusiasm. They force them. And they haven't built their empire by a shared enthusiasm for
他们没有用共同的热情建立他们的帝国
nice textiles and playing the panpipes. They have built it through force. And in terms of weaponry, they're kind of bronze age, aren't they? They've got slings and sort of axes and clubs and halberds made of bronze and they have quilted armor and they have kind of Greek style crested helmets with kind of feathers and stuff and they have nice little painted shields and whatnot and they have this horrible thing don't they where they come up against kind of enemy peoples and they say to the leaders of the enemy peoples you know join us and if you do then you know you'll become one of us and you can have a great time with guinea pigs and gold tweezers and things.
精美的纺织品和吹奏排箫。他们通过武力建立起这个帝国。在武器方面，他们有点像青铜时代，对吧？他们有投石索、各种斧头、棍棒以及青铜戟，还有棉甲，以及某种带有羽毛之类的古希腊风格羽饰头盔，他们还有精美的小彩绘盾牌之类的东西，而且他们有一种可怕的做法，不是吗？就是当他们遇到某种敌对民族时，他们会对敌对民族的首领说，你知道的，加入我们，如果你这样做了，那么，你知道的，你就会成为我们的一员，你可以和豚鼠、黄金镊子之类的好东西一起过上好日子。
Yeah. And if you don't and you fight and then you get captured, they'll bring you back to the capital and they'll dig these huge pits and they'll put in kind of snakes and hungry jaguars and things. Yeah. And then if you survive it,
是的。如果你不加入并选择抵抗然后被俘，他们会把你带回首都，挖出巨大的深坑，里面放上各种蛇和饥饿的美洲虎之类动物。是的。如果你能挺过去，
then you get pulled up and live as a servant. And if you don't, you get killed by these snakes and things. I'll just put my cards on the table here. I would not have liked to have lived in the Inca Empire. I think it sounds like a terrible place. I mean, this will shock our Peruvian listeners. Well, no, I mean, you have to wear this monochrome clothing. You have to spend your whole time digging roads.
那么你就会被拉上来，作为奴仆活下去。如果你挺不过去，就会被这些蛇之类的东西杀死。我在这里先把我的底牌亮明。我是绝对不愿意生活在印加帝国的。我觉得听起来真是一个糟糕透顶的地方。我的意思是，这会震惊到我们的秘鲁听众。好吧，不，我的意思是，你必须穿这种单调颜色的衣服。你必须把所有时间都花在挖路上。
Yeah. If you rebel, you might end up in a pit with a snake. Yeah. I mean, it's not fun. They have absorbed all these surrounding peoples into their empire. And part of it is by persuading their elites to join the Incan nobility. And to be an Incan nobleman is quite a laugh. You get like a palace.
是的。如果你反叛，你最后可能会掉进有蛇的坑里。是的。我的意思是，这可一点也不好玩。他们将所有这些周围的民族都吞并进他们的帝国。其中的一部分手段是说服当地的精英阶层加入印加贵族。当一名印加贵族是一件挺快活的事。你能得到诸如宫殿之类的赏赐。
You get the best food and drink. You get to use some of these roads are just for the nobility. You get to travel in a litter on these roads. And you get to wear these golden plugs in your ear. earlobes, earplugs. They sort of widen out your earlobe. Would that be a selling point for you? I think it would be worth a try.
你能享受最好的食物和饮用水。有些路是专门供贵族使用的，你也能使用这些路。你可以在这些路上坐着轿子出行。你还可以在耳垂上戴这种金耳塞。耳塞。它们会把你的耳垂撑大。这对你来说会是一个卖点吗？我觉得值得一试。
And the Spanish called them for that reason the Oriones, the big ears. That's the Spanish name for the Incanability, the Big Ears. However, to be a peasant is awful. So basically the Aztecs, if the Aztecs conquered you, the Aztecs just wants you to send them some lovely beans as a tribute every year or whatever. You know, some chocolate or whatever. The Inkers aren't really that bothered about the tribute. What they want is you.
正因如此，西班牙人称他们为“奥里奥内斯”（Oriones），即“大耳朵”。这是西班牙人对印加贵族的称呼，“大耳朵”。然而，当一个农民可就太惨了。所以基本上，如果是阿兹特克人征服了你，阿兹特克人只希望你每年送给他们一些可爱的豆子作为贡品之类的东西。你知道的，一些巧克力什么的。印加人其实并不那么在乎贡品。他们想要的是你。
They want your labour. So it's kind of a bit like Maoist China. You have to wear the same clothes and just spend your whole time being bossed around by apparatchiks, making do roads. Well, it's actually more like Stalin's Soviet Union, actually. So you will be called up regularly under a system called the META, the Turn. You'll be called up to work on huge state farms and state construction projects. All these people who've built all these roads and bridges and stuff
他们想要你的劳动力。所以这有点像毛泽东时代的中国。你必须穿一样的衣服，把所有的时间都花在听从官僚的颐指气使、修建道路上。嗯，实际上这更像斯大林的苏联。所以你会根据一个叫做“米达”（Mita，即轮役制）的制度被定期征召。你会被召集去大型国有农场和国家建设项目工作。所有这些建造了所有这些道路、桥梁之类的人，
are conscripts working in basically slave gangs, chain gangs. They belong to the emperor. There is no private property in the Inca Empire. There is no free market. In fact, there is no market of any kind. There are no markets, which is mind boggling. There is no money. There is no private ownership of land.
其实都是在奴隶工队、苦役犯工队中劳动的被征召者。他们属于皇帝。印加帝国没有私有财产。没有自由市场。事实上，根本没有任何形式的市场。这里没有市场，这简直令人匪夷所思。没有货币。没有土地私有制。
Land is held in common. In other words, it's kind of, well, Latin American Marxists in the 60s and 70s used to talk about Inca communism, and they said, this is brilliant. You know, no private property. There's no hunger because the food is kind of distributed by the state, all of this. But more right-wing historians, you know, write of this with horror. So Hugh Thomas, who ended up being a sort of very fatter-adjacent peer in their 1980s. Incredibly boring historian.
土地归公。换句话说，这有点……嗯，20世纪60和70年代的拉丁美洲马克思主义者过去常常谈论印加共产主义，他们说，这太棒了。你知道的，没有私有财产。没有饥饿，因为食物是由国家分配的，诸如此类。但更右翼的历史学家则以惊恐的笔调书写这一切。因此，休·托马斯（Hugh Thomas）在20世纪80年代成了一名亲上议院派的贵族。极其无聊的历史学家。
Cannot write an interesting sentence. Like, his books are simultaneously incredibly long, but incredibly unsatisfying, no? Yeah. Just lists of the genealogy of conquistadors. So and so, who was from Trujillo, whose brother actually was the bishop of whatever, and he just goes on and on and on. And actually the guy is fighting a battle on the rope bridge at this moment, but Hugh Thomas is more interested in telling you
写不出一句有趣的话。就像他的书一样，既极其漫长，又极其令人不满足，不是吗？是的。只是一堆征服者的家谱。某某人，来自特鲁希略，其兄弟实际上是某某地方的主教，他没完没了地讲下去。而实际上此时此刻那家伙正在绳桥上浴血奋战，但休·托马斯却更愿意告诉你
that his uncle once went to Casares and, I don't know, anyway, whatever. Hugh Thomas says of the incurs system, personal liberty was practically non-existent. Blind obedience and unquestioning self-abnegation had forever to be accorded. never was there a more pervasive government than that of the Inca's. And I think there is something a bit chilling about it. So basically, if they conquered you or if you did a deal with them,
他的叔叔曾经去过卡萨雷斯，而且，我不知道，总之，随便吧。休·托马斯对印加制度的评价是：个人自由几乎不存在。人们永远必须给予盲目的服从和毫不犹豫的自我牺牲。从来没有比印加人更无孔不入的政府了。我认为其中确实有一些令人不寒栗的东西。所以基本上，如果他们征服了你，或者你与他们达成了某种协议，
they would take like thousands of people and deliberately move them like Stalin and the Caucasus to the other end of the empire to work on a huge farm and forced them to speak Quechua, which wasn't their language. And there's something very, not totalitarian, but something very top-down and joyless and cold about it, I would say. question. Yeah. If you're an Andean peasant, just suppose, would you rather be conquered by the Incas or the Spanish? I don't think it's a bundle of laughs either way, to be honest with you,
他们会把成千上万的人像斯大林对待高加索人那样，故意迁移到帝国的另一端去在一个巨大的农场干活，并强迫他们说克丘亚语，而那并不是他们的语言。而且我觉得其中有一种非常——倒谈不上是极权主义，但有一种非常自上而下、毫无乐趣且冷冰冰的东西。这是一个问题。是的。如果你是一个安第斯农民，假设一下，你宁愿被印加人征服还是被西班牙人征服？说实话，我觉得无论哪一种都算不上什么快活事，
because the Spanish, as we will see, behave quite poorly at times. Do they behave as poorly as the Inca, so? It's a tough one. I mean, surely you get fiestas with the Spanish. Mariachi bands, you're thinking Mexico. You're in Mexico, Tom. I think you have fiestas in Peru, don't you? Yeah, but more Pampite-based, no? That's fine.
因为正如我们将会看到的，西班牙人在有时表现得相当糟糕。那他们的表现有印加人那么糟糕吗？这是一个棘手的问题。我的意思是，跟西班牙人在一起肯定能过节日吧？马里亚奇乐队，你想的是墨西哥。你在墨西哥，汤姆。我觉得秘鲁也有节日，对吧？是的，但更偏向排箫风格，对吧？没关系。
That's the fusion of cultures. Yeah. I don't know. I think possibly I'm going to go with the Spanish just because I'm European. I'm Eurocentric person. So for that reason. The Inkers do all this, of course, with no writing. And do you know what they use instead of writing? They have these things called kipus, which are long rows of knotted looped strings. I did know that. No one really knows how they work, because a lot of them were destroyed in the Spanish conquest. And historians have puzzled some of them out. But basically, you get a load of string where they're not. and that could be the census. Yeah, well, it's kind of like an abacus, isn't it? I mean, it's that kind of thing. Exactly. It could be anything. However, all the sort of suffocating uniformity of the Inca Empire maybe is a little bit, I think might be a little bit overstated. Because if you take the example of religion, we know that the Inca's try to enforce their gods on the people whom they conquered.
那是文化的融合。是的。我不知道。我想我可能还是会选西班牙人，仅仅因为我是欧洲人。我是个欧洲中心主义者。所以出于这个原因。当然，印加人所有这一切都是在没有文字的情况下完成的。你知道他们用什么来代替文字吗？他们有被称为“奇普”（Quipus）的东西，那是一行行打结、成环的绳子。我确实知道这一点。没有人真正知道它们是如何运作的，因为其中许多都在西班牙征服期间被毁了。历史学家们已经破解了其中一部分。但基本上，你拿到一堆打了结的绳子，这可能就是人口普查。是的，嗯，这有点像算盘，不是吗？我的意思是，就是那种东西。完全正确。这可能是任何东西。然而，印加帝国那种令人窒息的整齐划一，也许被稍微、我觉得可能被稍微夸大了。因为如果我们以宗教为例，我们知道印加人试图将他们的神强加给他们征服的人民。
So particularly, it seems like Patrick Couty and his success has tried to enforce an official cult of the sun god linked to their own dynasty. And the sun god was called Inti. And the Inca priests said, he gave the gift of civilization to patricute his ancestor, it was called Manco Capac, supposedly. And our emperor is therefore the son of the sun. And, you know, you should venerate him and all this kind of thing. So like Japan. Yeah.
特别是，看起来帕查库特克（Pachacuti）和他的继承人试图强加一种与他们自己的王朝相联系的太阳神官方崇拜。太阳神被称为因蒂（Inti）。印加祭司说，他将文明的恩赐赐予了帕查库特克的祖先，据说那个人叫曼科·卡帕克（Manco Capac）。因此我们的皇帝是太阳之子。而且，你知道的，你们应该崇拜他以及所有诸如此类的事情。所以就像日本一样。是的。
However, we know the Spanish discovered that all the different local people still had their own cults and their own shrines and their own gods. So, I mean, that's not surprising. And I guess that that would also work actually in the dimension of, you know, what you want to wear and whether you have to go and get. build roads or whatever, is that I imagine that off those main roads, there is actually a degree of autonomy, I would suspect.
然而，我们知道西班牙人发现所有不同的当地人仍然保留着他们自己的信仰、他们自己的神龛和他们自己的神。所以，我的意思是，这并不令人意外。而且我猜，这在……你知道的，你想穿什么衣服，以及你是否必须去建造道路之类的事情上，实际上也会发挥作用，那就是我猜在那些主干路之外，实际上存在着一定程度的自治，我会这样猜测。
I mean, I don't see that you can impose that degree of uniformity over people who live kind of 10 miles away, you know, up a mountain. I think you're right. I think the Inkers are trying to impose a uniformity as part of the empire building project. But I think, as we will discover, a lot of local groups bitterly resist that and actually hate the Inkers,
我的意思是，我不认为你可以把那种程度的整齐划一强加给那些住在大概10英里外、大山深处的人们。我想你是对的。我认为印加人试图将整齐划一强加于人，作为其帝国建设工程的一部分。但我认为，正如我们将要发现的，许多当地群体对此进行顽强的抵抗，并且实际上痛恨印加人，
rather light with the Aztecs when the Spanish arrived in Mexico. There are a load of people who actually said, well, I mean, sure, I'm not a massive fan of the Spanish, but I'll tell you who I really hate. It's the people who've been lauding it over us for the last 150 years. And this is the case, I think, with the Inca's. So in the Inca Empire, for example, the official language is Quechua. But millions of Inca's don't speak Quechua. Millions of Inca subjects, I should say.
正如西班牙人抵达墨西哥时阿兹特克人的遭遇那样。有大量的人实际上说，好吧，我的意思是，当然，我不是西班牙人的超级粉丝，但我告诉你我真正恨的是谁。正是那些在过去150年里一直在我们头上作威作福的人。我认为印加帝国的情况也是如此。因此，在印加帝国，例如，官方语言是克丘亚语。但数以百万计的印加人并不说克丘亚语。更准确地说，是数以百万计的印加属民。
So they would speak Aymara or Pukina or Machika or all these other languages many of which are now lost. And they chafe, I think, under the jack boot of the Quechua speakers from Kusko. And so when the Spanish arrive, I think there are probably a lot of people who think, you know, the Spanish are not a bundle of laughs. They will behave very badly. But if they will guarantee us a little bit more autonomy. I mean, I imagine if you're an Andean peasant, you assume that anyone with power
所以他们会说艾马拉语、普基纳语、马奇卡语或所有其他许多现在已经失传的语言。我认为，他们在库斯科克丘亚语使用者的铁蹄下感到备受压迫。因此，当西班牙人到来时，我想可能会有很多人觉得，你知道的，西班牙人可算不上什么快活事。他们的表现会非常糟糕。但如果他们能保证给我们多一点点的自治权。我的意思是，我想如果你是一个安第斯农民，你会认为任何拥有权力的人
is going to behave badly. Yeah, I think it's just relative, you know, who's going to be worse. Now, with the Aztecs, we talked. before about how diversity was not their strength, how the Spanish were brilliant at using this against them, and this would be the case here as well. But here it's slightly different, because the Inca's are even more vulnerable than the Aztecs. And this takes us back to the scene that had confronted Pizarro and Co when they landed on the coast. And they found the devastation and the deserted streets and the looted temples. At the beginning of the 16th century,
表现都不会好到哪里去。是的，我认为这只是相对而言，你知道的，谁会更糟糕。现在，说到阿兹特克人，我们之前谈到过多样性并不是他们的强项，西班牙人是如何精于利用这一点来对付他们的，这里的情况也将同样如此。但在这里略有不同，因为印加人比阿兹特克人更加脆弱。这把我们带回了皮萨罗一行人登陆海岸时面对的景象。他们发现了满目疮痍、荒芜的街道和洗劫一空的寺庙。在16世纪初，
so the time when Pizarro is arriving in the Caribbean, 1500 or so, the emperor of the Inca's, the 11th Sapa Inca, as he was called, was this bloke called Huena Capac, who was Patrick Coutis' grandson. And Hwena Capac is clearly a very impressive guy. He built those of temples, he built those of roads, he annexed a lot of what's now Ecuador and Bolivia. He pushed as far north as Colombia.
也就是皮萨罗抵达加勒比地区的时候，大约1500年前后，印加帝国的皇帝，即第11代萨帕·印加（Sapa Inca，正如他被称为的那样），是一个叫韦纳·卡帕克（Huayna Capac）的家伙，他是帕查库特克的孙子。韦纳·卡帕克显然是一个非常了不起的人物。他修建了大量寺庙，修建了大量道路，吞并了现在厄瓜多尔和玻利维亚的大片领土。他向北推进到了哥伦比亚。
It's quite possible that he was the first emperor to hear reports of the Spanish arrival in the Americas. So he probably would have got garbable, news from Panama, because he's gone up into Columbia in the next country, up is Panama. So he's probably heard garbled news, there's some blokes with beards who turned up who are like laying waste and behaving poorly. So he may have known that the Spanish are coming. But the threat to him in his empire is not the Spanish themselves, it's what they bring from Europe, which is smallpox. So smallpox had arrived in the new world in the 1510s. It had ripped through the Caribbean,
他很有可能是第一个听到有关西班牙人抵达美洲报告的皇帝。所以他可能从巴拿马得到了断续的、失真的消息，因为他已经一路向上走到了哥伦比亚，下一个往上的国家就是巴拿马。所以他可能听到了走样传闻，说是有一些带着胡子的人出现了，他们到处搞破坏而且表现恶劣。所以他可能已经知道西班牙人要来了。但他和他的帝国面临的威胁根本不是西班牙人本身，而是他们从欧洲带来的东西，那就是天花。所以天花在1510年代就已经抵达了新世界。它像狂风骤雨般肆虐加勒比地区，
killing the vast majority of the indigenous population, and then it had killed colossal numbers of people in Mexico and Central America. It gets to Central America in the 1520s or so, then it goes down Central America, down the Isthmus of Panama, into Colombia, into the very place where Hwena Kappak is campaigning with his army. It hits the army first, probably in about 1525, then it spreads to the court, it kills Huena Kappak's eldest son,
杀死了绝大多数的原住民人口，接着又在墨西哥和中美洲杀死了大量的人口。它在1520年代左右到达中美洲，然后向下穿过中美洲，顺着巴拿马地峡，进入哥伦比亚，进入韦纳·卡帕克正带着他的军队进行远征的那个地方。它首先袭击了军队，大约在1525年左右，然后蔓延到宫廷，杀死了韦纳·卡帕克的大儿子，
and then around about between 1525 and 1527 or so, he gets it too and within days he is dead. This disease to which nobody in the Americas has any immunity. And for the Inca's, the death of the emperor from this unknown disease is an absolutely shattering pivotal moment. They have no system of primogeniture. So the next sun in line does not have an automatic right to rule. Basically, the system works on constant succession crises.
接着大约在1525年至1527年左右，他也染上了天花，几天之内便命丧黄泉。这是一种美洲没有任何免疫力的疾病。对于印加人来说，皇帝死于这种未知的疾病，是一个绝对粉碎性的、具有转折意义的时刻。他们没有长子继承制。因此排在长序首位的下一个儿子并不自动拥有统治权。基本上，这个制度靠的是不断的继承危机。
There's a crown, which is a kind of, it might sound slightly peculiar to listeners who are used to crowns. It's a kind of circlet of red cords with a tassel that hangs down. If you have the tassel, that shows that you're the king, the emperor. This circlet will go not to the eldest, but to the strongest. And there are two obvious contenders for the crown, as we should call it. So one of them is Hwena Kappak's son, Huasgar, probably son by his first wife, and Huasca's power base is in the traditional Inca heartland of Kusko. But he's an absolute lush, isn't he?
有一个王冠，它是一种……对于习惯了王冠的听众来说可能会觉得有点奇特。它是一种红色细绳做成的圆环，上面垂下一个流苏。如果你拥有这个流苏，就表明你是国王，是皇帝。这个圆环不会传给长子，而是传给最强者。对于王冠（我们姑且这么称呼它）有两个显而易见的竞争者。其中之一是韦纳·卡帕克的儿子瓦斯卡尔（Huascar），可能是他与第一任妻子的儿子，瓦斯卡尔的权力基础在印加传统的腹地库斯科。但他是个十足的酒鬼，不是吗？
Do you think so? He's a lush. Yeah. I think this is harsh. He spends his whole time having drunken parties. That's what people say, but I think this is propaganda, actually. I think this is Attawalp and Propaganda. Because the other son is called Attawalpa.
你这么觉得吗？他是个酒鬼。是的。我觉得这太苛刻了。他把所有时间都花在办酒会上。人们都这么说，但我认为这实际上是宣传。我认为这是阿塔瓦尔帕的宣传。因为另一个儿子叫阿塔瓦尔帕（Atahualpa）。
And Attawelper is younger. from a different wife. Atulpa's probably about 30. Probably his mother came from Quito, which is the capital city today of Ecuador. And that tension between what's now Ecuador and what's now Peru is a huge, huge part of this story, North versus South, basically. So Atowalpa doesn't have any particular loyalty to Kuzco? No, not to north. His loyalty is to Quito in the north. What ends up happening is Huascair becomes the emperor. And he says to his younger brother Atta Welper, well, you can be my viceroy in the north. You can rule in
阿塔瓦尔帕更年轻，是另一个妻子生的。阿塔瓦尔帕大概30岁左右。他的母亲可能来自基多，也就是今天厄瓜多尔的首都。现在厄瓜多尔和秘鲁之间的这种紧张关系是这个故事中极其重要的一部分，基本上就是北方对南方的对抗。所以阿塔瓦尔帕对库斯科没有任何特殊的忠诚？不，对北方没有。他效忠的是北方的基多。最终发生的情况是瓦斯卡尔成了皇帝。他对自己的弟弟阿塔瓦尔帕说，嗯，你可以做我在北方的总督。你可以在
Quito, I'll rule in Kusko. There's 2,000 miles between these places. I mean, that gives you a sense of how huge this empire is. But it's very, very, I mean, it's a very trite comparison, but I'm just going to go there because that's what we do. It is very Game of Thrones, the potential for
基多统治，我在库斯科统治。这两个地方相距2,000英里。我的意思是，这让你对这个帝国有多么巨大有了一个概念。但这非常非常……我的意思是，这是一个非常陈腐的比较，但我还是要用它，因为这就是我们的风格。它非常像《权力的游戏》，那种关于
you know, who's going to get the ultimate prize. And by about 1529, relations between the two brothers have broken down. There's a civil war. now we're dependent on later Spanish accounts for the Civil War so it's a bit murky clearly this is a regional as well as a factional thing Kito in the North versus Kusko in the South that's really important
谁将获得终极奖赏的潜力。到了1529年左右，两兄弟之间的关系彻底破裂。爆发了一场内战。现在我们只能依赖后来的西班牙关于内战的记载，所以情况有点模糊。显然这是一场地方性的冲突，也是一场派系冲突，北方的基多对南方的库斯科，这非常重要。
it's extremely vicious so basically if you side with one brother and the other brothers troops turn up they will take hideous reprisals on you and so the longer the Civil War goes on the more damage it does to the Empire's infrastructure and unity and it goes on for a long time so it takes takes three years before Attawalpa, the younger brother, the bloke from the north, from Quito, before he gets an advantage. And in April 1532, his generals win a big victory over his brother's forces outside Kusko. They capture Huaskar, the older brother, and Atowalpa's army can now lay siege to Kusko itself. Now this has come, you know, victory is at hand, but it's come
这极其残酷。所以基本上，如果你站在一个兄弟一边，而另一个兄弟的军队出现了，他们会对你进行可怕的报复。因此，内战持续的时间越长，对帝国基础设施和统一性的破坏就越大。而且这场战争持续了很长时间，花了三年时间，阿塔瓦尔帕——这个来自北方基多的年轻弟弟——才取得优势。在1532年4月，他的将领们在库斯科城外对他的兄弟的军队取得了一场大胜。他们俘虏了哥哥瓦斯卡尔，现在阿塔瓦尔帕的军队可以对库斯科城本身发动围攻了。现在，胜利可以说是
at a great cost to him and his empire. He personally has established a reputation for incredible cruelty. So if Spanish writers are to be believed, he would order enemy chief's hearts to be torn out and he would make their supporters eat them. Doesn't he behave very badly to poor old Huascar's kind of nearest and dearest? Yeah, very bad. He rounds up all his wives, all his children,
唾手可得，但这对他和他的帝国来说付出了巨大的代价。他个人确立了极其残忍的名声。所以如果西班牙作家的记载可信的话，他会下令挖出敌方首领的心脏，并强迫他们的支持者吃掉。他对待可怜的老瓦斯卡尔的至亲之人的表现是不是也非常糟糕？是的，非常糟糕。他抓来他所有的妻子、所有的孩子，
tortures them to death, then sticks their bodies on massive great spikes. along the road. And I suppose effectively by doing that, he is destroying not just Huasca status as a king, but any prospect of him establishing his dynasty. His bloodline. Exactly. His bloodline.
把他们折磨至死，然后把他们的尸体插在巨大的尖桩上，沿着道路排开。我想，通过这样做，他实际上不仅在消灭瓦斯卡尔作为国王的地位，而且在消灭他建立自己王朝的一切前景。他的血脉。没错。他的血脉。
And Huasca, supposedly, was forced to watch while his wives and children were being tortured. Atwalpazamis and Huasca's armies have done tremendous damage to towns and cities, the length of the empire from Quito to Kuzco. And they've divided that the ruling Inca elite itself has been completely splintered. So to quote the Mexican historian Fernando Savantes, the incanability on which the system had largely relied was now irreparably torn. The scars of the war were too fresh, too painful, and only too obvious. And isn't there a kind of Romans destroying Carthage scenario where Atahelpa basically tells everyone in Cusco,
据说瓦斯卡尔被迫眼睁睁地看着自己的妻子和孩子遭受折磨。阿塔瓦尔帕的军队和瓦斯卡尔的军队对从基多到库斯科的帝国全境的城镇和城市造成了巨大的破坏。他们把统治印加帝国的精英阶层本身分化得四分五裂。用墨西哥历史学家费尔南多·塞万提斯（Fernando Cervantes）的话来说：“系统所主要依赖的印加贵族阶层如今已经无可挽回地撕裂了。战争的伤痕太新鲜、太痛苦，而且过于显眼了。”
you've got to leave. You've got to come to Quito. I'm going to wipe out Cusco, you know, abandon your temples, all of that. Yeah, so at this point, Cusco has not yet fallen, but Atta Welper is clearly a very vengeful person, and he is determined. You know, he associates Cusco with his brother's faction and with rebellion. All his commanders tend to be from the north. His family are from the north. And his investment in, as it were, the traditional Inca heartland is not great.
难道没有那种罗马人毁灭迦太基的情景吗？阿塔瓦尔帕基本上告诉库斯科的所有人，你们必须离开。你们必须来基多。我要抹去库斯科，你知道的，放弃你们的寺庙，所有这一切。是的，所以在这个时候，库斯科还没有陷落，但阿塔瓦尔帕显然是一个非常记仇的人，而且他心意已决。你知道的，他把库斯科与他兄弟的派系和叛乱联系在一起。他的指挥官往往来自北方。他的家人来自北方。而且他对作为传统印加腹地的感情并不深。
And actually, I think there was a lot of, I think there's a case that a lot of people in the central and south Inca Empire view Atta Walper and his troops as outsiders. As foreigners or almost. As foreigners from the north, exactly. Now, this doesn't have to be fatal for Atualpa. He's won, right? I mean, he can, with time, he can rebuild the incinability. You know, he can establish himself. He can stitch up the wounds of war.
实际上，我认为有很多人，我认为有理由认为中央和南部印加帝国的许多人都将阿塔瓦尔帕和他的军队视为外来者。差不多就像外国人一样。就像来自北方的外国人，完全没错。现在，这不一定会给阿塔瓦尔帕带来致命打击。他赢了，对吧？我的意思是，随着时间的推移，他可以重建印加贵族阶层。你知道的，他可以确立自己的地位。他可以缝合战争的伤口。
He can kill everybody he doesn't like. You know, he could be the emperor for another 30 years or something. But, of course, he doesn't know that time is the one thing that he does not have. Because this takes us back to the Spaniards who are knackered. hungry, sodden with sweat, but are now learning the reality about this empire. But just to remind people, 168 Spaniards. So these Spaniards, they don't know everything we know about the Inca's, but what they do know now, thanks to their informants,
他可以杀掉所有他不喜欢的人。你知道的，他可以再做30年左右的皇帝。但是，当然，他并不知道时间是他唯一没有的东西。因为这把我们带回了那些精疲力竭、饥饿难耐、浑身被汗水湿透，但现在正在了解这个帝国真相的西班牙人身上。但还是要提醒大家，只有168个西班牙人。所以这些西班牙人，他们并不像我们那样知道关于印加人的一切，但他们现在所知道的，多亏了他们的线报，
is that to the south there is this vast empire with extraordinary wealth, but it's divided, it is battle-scarred, it is ripe for the take. speaking. And Francisco Pizarro, this illegitimate, illiterate, bruiser from Western Spain, he doesn't hesitate he knows exactly what to do. And so now the Spaniards road lies south to a showdown with Attawalpa in the town of Kayamaka, to the temples and treasure houses of the Inca's capital Kusko, and finally to a quest into the jungle to find the last, lost city of the Inca's. showdowns, lost cities. This really is a series that has it all. We have five episodes to come. And the tremendous news for members of the rest is history club, our very own band of bedraggled but
那就是在南方有这样一个庞大的帝国，拥有非凡的财富，但它四分五裂，饱受战火摧残，正等待着被征服。说真的。弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗这个来自西班牙西部的私生子、目不识丁的粗人，他毫不犹豫，他非常清楚该怎么做。所以现在西班牙人的道路向南延伸，去卡亚玛卡镇与阿塔瓦尔帕摊牌，去印加首都库斯科的寺庙和宝库，最后去丛林中探寻印加人最后的失落之城。巅峰对决，失落之城。这真是一个应有尽有的系列节目。我们还有五集精彩内容。对于“历史其余部分”（Rest is History）俱乐部会员们——我们这群衣衫褴褛却冷酷无情的征服者——来说，最大的好消息是，你可以立刻收听全部五集节目。如果你想报名加入我们对印加帝国的血腥突袭，那么你可以前往therestishistory.com网站并在那里完成报名。但现在，再见。拜拜。拜拜。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。
ruthless conquistadors, is that you can hear all five episodes right away. And if you would like to sign up to join us on our murderous assault on the Incan Empire, then you can head to the rest is history.com and do it there. But for now, Asteroego. Bye-bye. Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
敹攢的吁兵，即可甛内听到所有五集。如果您想加入我们对印卡帝国的杀戮之旅，可以访问theresthistory.com来加入。但目前先这样，兰斯特吉。再见。再见。本集节尚无评论。点击译文中的任何句子即可留言。